Hallo und herzlich willlkommen zu Forschergeist, der ersten Ausgabe. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und wie wir hier schon in unserer kurzen Ankündigungsfolge deutlich gemacht haben, wollen wir uns hier unterhalten über Wissenschaft, Wissenschaft erklären, aber vor allem nicht so viel Forschung selber besprechen, sondern eben auch viel erfahren darum, wie Wissenschaft organisiert ist. wie das Wissenschaftssystem als solches funktioniert. Wie Wissenschaftler heutzutage arbeiten und wohin die Reise dort gehen kann. Und wenn man so ein bisschen versucht, in die Zukunft zu blicken, dann ist es ja auch immer ganz hilfreich, auch mal ein wenig in die Vergangenheit zu blicken, denn vieles ist in gewisser Hinsicht auch schon mal da gewesen und häufig sind manche Sachen auch nur deshalb in ihrem Jetztzustand wirklich verständlich, wenn man sich auch anschaut, wie sich das alles entwickelt hat. Und deswegen möchten wir hier in der ersten Folge genau das tun, nämlich ein wenig in die Geschichte schauen, in die Geschichte der Wissenschaft. Und dazu begrüße ich hier als Gesprächspartnerin Annette Vogt
Ja herzlich Willkommen.
Schönen guten Tag, herzlich Willkommen bei Forschergeist. Sie sind beim Max-Planck-Institut für Wissenschaftsgeschichte?
Richtig.
Untergebracht am Standort.
In Dahlem. Wir sind in Berlin Dahlem.
Genau in Berlin Dahlem. Weiß nicht, der Standort ist wahrscheinlich sehr breit aufgestellt mit der Max-Planck-Gesellschaft. Was findet da sonst noch alles statt?
Oh, unsere Max-Planck-Gesellschaft hat über 80 Institute. Die meisten beschäftigen sich mit der "harten Wissenschaft", Physik, Chemie, Medizin, Biologie, Molekulargenetik. Und dann gibt es eine geisteswissenschaftliche Sektion. Zu der gehören unter anderem zwei kunsthistorische Institute. In Rom die Bibliotheca Hertziana und in Florenz und unser Institut für Wissenschaftsgeschichte. Und unser Standort ist BErlin Dahlem. Wer sich in BErlin auskennt, in der Nähe vom Henry-Ford-Bau, von der freien Universität.
Ist das was seltenes. Also ist jetzt nicht so, dass jeder Standort eine Forschung zu Wissenschaftsgeschichte aufweisen könnte.
Es ist etwas seltenes. Das Institut ist noch relativ jung, verglichen mit Max-Planck-Instituten, die auf 70-80 Jahre zurückblicken. Wir sind 1994 gegründet worden und einer der Gründe ist, dass das Fach Wissenschaftsgeschichte wichtig ist, aber an den Universitäten noch nicht so wirklich gut verankert und entwickelt ist. Und deshalb ist dann unser Max-Planck-Institut gegründet worden, mit einer breiten Ausrichtung, mit einer sehr internationaleln Ausrichtung. Weil das ist ja auch wichtig, Wissenschaft ist ja nichts nationales. Da kommen wir ja sicher noch drauf. Sie wird zwar national finanziert, betrieben, aber sie ist per Definition etwas internationales.
Ja.
Und deshalb ist auch eine internationale Ausrichtung wichtig.
Also internationale Ausrichtung im Sinne von, dass man mit anderen internationalen Forschern gemeinsam forscht oder dass das Forschungsfeld von Vornherein international ist?
Es ist beides. Das Forschungsfeld ist international und natürlich kooperieren wir sehr viel mit Kollegen von China bis USA.
Wie ist denn Ihre eigene Geschichte zunächst einmal. Wie kommt man denn dahin? Womit hat das denn begonnen?
Zur Wissenschaftsgeschichte kann man auf zwei Wegen kommen. Und wenn wir gucken, international gibt es auch immer diese beiden Möglichkeiten. Man studiert Geschichte oder Philosophie oder Wissenschaftstheorie und interessiert sich von dort dann für die Geschichte der Wissenschaft, und hat dann die IDee, ich betreibe eher Geschichte, als theoretische wissenschaftsphilosophische Fragestellungen zu behandlen. Oder der andere Weg ist, man studiert eine der Disziplinen. Also Wissenschaft ist ja aufgefächert von Archäologie bis Zoologie. Man studiert eine dieser Disziplinen und interessiert sich dann für die Geschichte der Disziplin. Und stellt dann natürlich Querbezüge her und versucht mit Hilfe von philosophischen Fragestellungen anders auf die Geschichte dieser Disziplin zu gucken, als wenn man es machen würde, nur als Mathematiker zur Geschichte der Mathematik zu gucken. Und bei mir ist es in der Tat dieser zweite Weg gewesen. Ich habe Mathematik studiert. Ich habe auch mein Diplom in Mathematik. Und das habe ich damals gemacht zur Fragestellung in der Funktionalanalysis. Und wenn Sie Mathematik studieren, wir Mathematiker haben dann gerne Sätze nach Personen benannt. Und dann hören Sie was von der Eulerschen Zahl. Vom Cauchyschen-Konvergenzkriterium oder vom Satz von Weierstraß oder die Riemannsche Vermutung, die bis heute immer noch nicht bewiesen ist übrigens und dann sagt man sich, ja wer waren die? Und warum haben die dieses entwickelt? Und was ist da passiert? Und so bin ich also zur Geschichte der
Mathematik gekommen und fand das dann also spannender als zu sitzen und zu versuchen, ein Lemma zu beweisen oder die Riemannsche Vermutung.
Zu knifflig.
Ja nee, die Riemannsche Vermutung ist wichtig heutzutage, weil da geht es um die Zahlentheorie, da geht es um die Verteilung der Primzahl. Und Riemann hatte eben vermutet, wie die sich verteilen und mit Hilfe der Computer kann man die Primzahlen finden und bis jetzt scheint es so, dass diese Vermutung stimmt, aber es ist kein mathematischer Beweis bis jetzt gegeben worden.
Naja Primzahlen und so, Kryptografie ist alles nicht ganz unwichtig.
Wobei der Bernhard Riemann ein Mathematiker, der in Göttingen gelehrt hat, der hat die also so um 1854 aufgestellt. So alt ist die also schon.
Ja, wo haben Sie Mathematik studiert?
Ich habe Mathematik in Leipzig studiert. Da war damals - also ich komme aus der DDR und Leipzig gehörte zu den Zentren neben Berlin in der Mathematik, wo eine sehr gute Mathematikausbildung gemacht wurde und das war auch der Grund. Also mein VAter war Mathematiklehrer, der hatte also gewusst, geh nicht da und da hin. Sondern gehe entweder nach Berlin oder nach Leipzig und dann habe ich in Leipzig studiert und in Leipzig gibt es das Sudhoff-Institut für die Geschichte Naturwissenschaften und Medizin. Und daher wusste ich dann, so was kann man auch professionell machen, Mathematikgeschichte, nicht nur als Hobby. Oder wie viele Mathematiker denken, für emeritierte Professoren, die machen dann Mathematikgeschichte.
Und jetzt das Institut bei der Max-Planck-Gesellschaft ist das so ein reines Forschungsinstitut oder wird da auch Lehre betrieben?
Ja, wie alle Max-Planck-Institute ist das Max-Planck-Institut für Wissenschaftsgeschichte ein Forschungsinstitut unsere Mitarbeiter, wir können Lehre anbieten, aber wir müssen nicht. Und die meisten von den älteren Kollegen bieten auch irgendwelche Lehrveranstaltungen an, weil das natürlich wichtig ist, dass man die Beziehungen zu den Studenten hat. Also jeder der Lehrerfahrung  hat, ich selber biete auch Lehrveranstaltungen an, zur allgemeinen Wissenschaftsgeschichte habe ich das Jahre lang gemacht, an der Humboldt-Universität. Und seit einigen Jahren biete ich an "Historia STatistics" an der wirtschaftswissenschaftlichen Fakultät. Der Kontakt zu Studenten ist, für jemanden, der nur (mit oder ohne Anfürhungsstriche) forscht, sehr interessant und wichtig. Weil die jungen Leute andere Fragen stellen können. Wenn sie interessiert sind, wenn man Glück hat und man hat interessierte Studenten.
Und die Hoffnung, dass das Thema als solches auch seinen Weg an die Unis zurückfindet?
Wir haben die Hoffnung. Wir haben die Hoffnung, dass im Zuge der Debatten um die Verbesserung der Ausbildung, Wissenschaftsgeschichte einen größeren Stellenraum einnimmt. Aus einem ganz einfachen Grund, mit der Einführung des Bachelorstudiums lernen die Studenten in all diesen Fächern ja nur einen kleinen Teil der Disziplin kennen und haben oft weder Zeit noch die Möglichkeit, das Fach zu überblicken. Und hier wäre Wissenschaftsgeschichte ein idealer Einstieg, in einer Art STudium Generale oder wie man immer das nennen will. Etwas zu vermitteln, dass Mathematik nicht nur aus Zahlentheorie besteht oder aus Geometrie oder aus Funktionalanalysis oder oder. Und das gilt für alle Fächer. Der zweite Grund wäre, man kann etwas über die professionellen Dinge vermitteln mit Hilfe der Wissenschaftsgeschichte. Auch etwas, wie ethische Fragen. Wir haben die Debatten über die Fälschungen im Labor und man könnte sehr schön mit Hilfe von Wissenschaftsgeschichte da eine Sensibilität entwickelt, ohne dass das so aufgesetzt wirkt und ohne dass man auf den nächsten Skandal warten muss. Das heißt Wissenschaftsgeschichte in den Universitäten sollte stärker entwickelt werden. Und iwe gesagt, unser Institut hat einen großen Zulauf von jungen Doktoranden aus aller Welt und es ist eben schade, wenn die dann Jobchancen wirklich nur in Großbrittannien oder in den USA finden. Weil die Chancen an deutschen Universitäten leider sehr gering sind.
Mit dieser speziellen Ausrichtung jetzt?
Ja, obwohl wir eben gerade in Deutschland eine alte Tradition haben. Im europäischen Vergleich gab es die ersten professionellen Institute für Naturwissenschaftsgeschichte und Medizingeschichte hier - übrigens also in Leipzig dieses Sudhoff-Institut, benannt nach einem Medizinhistoriker und in Berlin gab es auch ein Institut sehr früh für Naturwissenschaftsgeschichte und Medizin. Und insofern, es gibt Traditionen, an die man positiv anknüpfen könnte.
Dann kommen wir doch mal auf die Wissenschaftsgeschichte als solche und blättern mal ein wenig zurück. Und wir hatten im Vorfeld auch schon mal ein bisschen geschaut, wie weit müsste man denn eigentlich zurückschauen? Und im Prinzip kann man da ja fast eigentlich schon an - müsste man eigentlich auch an den Beginn der menschlichen Gesellschaftsbildung zurückschauen und da bietet sich natürlich vor allem so die Antike an, die ja eigentlich schon sehr früh, quasi durch die Philosophie, so ein bisschen Wissenschaft - weiß nicht, kann man das so sagen - erfunden hat?
Betrieben hat, das ist ein großer Streit, ob man das erfunden, entdecken nennen kann. In Astronomie und Mathematik kann man sogar noch weiter zurückgehen. Babylonia, die Ägypter, also der Pyramidenbau, als ein Symbol dafür, dass es mathematische Kenntnisse gegeben hat und astronomische Kenntnisse. Und da sind auch sehr sehr interessante Forschungen. Und da kann man immer noch - also wer jetzt von den Zuhörern wissenschaftshistorisch arbeiten will später, da gibt es noch ganz viele offene Forschungsfragen. Das hängt auch damit zusammen, da müssen wir mit Archäologen zusammenarbeiten und dann finden die also neue kleine Keilschrifttäfelchen und dann kann man da eventuell neue Fragen beantworten oder alte Fragen neu beantworten. Aber die Antike ist wichtig, weil mit der Antike verbinden wir Wissenschaft, wie wir sie heute noch verstehen. Dass das also ein System von Kenntnissen, von Wissen ist. Also im deutschen Wort Wissenschaft steht ja Wissen ist da mit enthalten. Und dass es Leute gibt, Menschen, meistens Männer, aber auch ein paar Frauen schon, die die Zeit hatten, die Möglichkeit hatten, nachzudenken, zu überlegen, und zu versuchen, diese einzelnen Wissensteile zu systematisieren, in ein gewisses System zu bringen. Und wir haben also die Anfänge der Philosophie und die Wissenschaftler damals waren aber gleichzeitig auch Mathematiker oder Astronom, also die Trennung in diese Disziplinen ist etwas, was erst sehr viel später erfolgt.
Es gab nur die Leute, die sich damit überhaupt beschäftigt haben und die die es nicht getan haben sozusagen.
Genau. Und es gab natürlicha auch Praktiker. Also so etwas, die hießen nicht Ingenieur, aber es gab so etwas wie Bauleute, denn gerade wenn man an diese heute noch Spuren dieser Riesenbauten denkt, dann brauchten die natürlich auch ein gewisses Wissen, in wie weit das theoretisch formuliert war, das ist dann oft eine interassante Forschungsfrage und wird auch neu betrachtet. Also gerade dieses praktische Wissen in Verbindung mit theoretischem Wissen, wie die Bezüge waren. Da gibt es international interesaante Forschungsprojekte. Die also eher zu dem Schluss kommen, dass das nicht so eine strikte Trennung war und dass die Übergänge fließend waren und der Austausch des Wissens. Und dann gab es eben auch schon welche, die versucht haben, das aufzuschreiben. Also wirklich zu überliefern den SChülern, wenn man so will. Also der jungen Generation. Und das sind dann halt die Bruchstücke, die wir an Quellen haben.
Ich meine grundsätzlich war es ja eigentlich shon immer so, dass die menschliche Entwicklung sich an gewonnenem Wissen orientiert. Also überhaupt so erst mal der Wechsel zum Ackerbau, das ganze Wissen darüber, dann eben diese frühen Methoden, Informationen auch schon zu speichern. Die Keilschrifttafeln, Hiroglyphen etc., später dann eben mit dem Papyros dann auch die Möglichkeit, das aufzuschreiben, damit ja auch das Ausbilden der Schrift. Das sind ja, muss ja eigentlich etwas gewesen sein, was diesen Gesellschaften, wenn man sie so überhaupt nennen kann damals, irgendwie klar gewesen sein muss. Dass das Wissen den Fortschritt bestimmt. Deswegen frage ich mich so ein bisschen, wann sich eigentlich dann das erste Mal so etwas wie Wissenschaft als eigene Disziplin so herausgebildet hat und woran man das festmachen kann.
Na man kann es - also es gibt sozusagen die Idee, dass Sie da sagen, in dem Moment, wo es Personengruppen gibt in diesen Gesellschaften, die hauptsächlich Wissenschaft machen können. Die dann also auch finanziert werden von den anderen, und wo von den anderen akzeptiert wird, das ist was spezielles und dafür müssen die die Freiräume haben.
Und die müssen jetzt nicht mit auf den Acker und miternten etc.
Genau. In dem Moment kann man dann von Wissenschaftler reden. Dass die also das tun, aber gleichzeitig natürlich wisssen, dass sie es in diesem Kontext dieser Gesellschaft tun, und auch für diese Gesellschaft. Und sehr oft war das angebunden an religiöse Tätigkeiten. Also Priester. Und wir wissen ja, dass es also sehr früh astronomische Kenntnisse favorisiert wurden, weil die sind wichtig. Die sind wichtig zur Bestimmung von Zeit und Ort und die sind wichtig, um diese Frühling, Sommer, Herbst.. also die Jahreszeiten zu bestimmen. Und insoferni st das also einerseits theoretisch, aber andererseits natürlich auch praktisches wichtiges Wissen.
Für Ernteplanung etc.
Ja. Oder wir wissen, dass die administrative Verwaltung eine gewisse Grundkenntnis braucht. Also wenn ein solcher Staat in dem Sinne Steuern einnnehmen will, dann braucht er Kundige, die das tun. Und die das dann auch aufschreiben. Und insofern sind die Bezüge am Anfang sehr eng. Und gerade für die Mathematik kann man das also sehr schön in der Antike zeigen, diese engen Bezüge.
Wer war denn jetzt so der erste Wissenschaftler, der sozusagen das offiziell zum BEruf hat machen dürfen und nicht mehr aufs Feld musste?
Das kann man nicht so fixieren. Weil ja auch die Überlieferungsgeschichte nicht so völlig komplett ist. Denn leider gibt es ja seit Beginn der Menschheitsgeschichte dann kriegerische Auseinandersetzungen und die Vernichtung von Quellen und wir wissen ja, die berühmte Bibliothek von Alexandria, die dann zerstört wurde mit den ganzen Papyrusrollen. Und deshalb ist die Überlieferung nicht so genau, dass man das fixieren kann, aber wir haben dann natürlich in der Philosophie- und Wissenschaftsgeschichte diese Tradition mit Aristoteles und Plato und von da an kann man auch sagen, dass die bewusst Wissen vermittelt haben, weitergegeben haben und dann gibt es eben diesen schönen Spruch, niemand der Mathematik unkundiger betrete diesen Raum. Das soll angeblich über Platos Akademie gestanden haben. Für mich als Mathematikerin und Mathematikhistorikern ist das natürlicih ein schöner Satz. Und man könnte sich natürlich wünschen, dass das heute auch anders gefordert wird. Dass also Mathematik eben wirklich ein wichtiger Bestandteil ist, für die alle, die Wissenschaft machen wollen.
Ja.
Wenn auch nicht der einzige.
Ja natürlich. Aber wie gesagt, das sind sozusagen die Anfänge. Und es gibt dann die ersten überlieferten Texte, die wir natürlich immer nur in Abschriften kennen oder in Übersetzungen kennen. Und insofern ist das natürlich was anderes, als wenn ich über das 16./17./18. Jahrhundert rede und dann wirklich Manuskripte noch in Bibliotheken oder in Archiven finde und weiß, das hat wirklich Galilei geschrieben, das ist seine Handschrift, das ist ein Manuskript. Während das andere alles über die antiken Autoren nur Vermittlungen sind.
So Homer und seine Freunde.
Ja, die sind ja dann viel abgeschrieben worden. Und dann gibt es eben die - weiß ich nicht - 147. Abschrift und dann sind die auch übersetzt worden ins Arabische, ins Lateinische und über solche Quellentexte kann man dann das versuchen, zu rekonstruieren.
Aber so diese ersten Philosophen der Antike - auf mich macht das immer so ein bisschen den Eindruck so, das sind alles solche Einzelkämpfer. Das sind so Leute, die einfach aus ihrem eigenen Antrieb heraus einfach diesen Wissensdurst verspürt haben und es sich dann in irgendeiner Form erarbeitet haben in dieser Gesellschaft, sozusagen als Wissenschaftler zu arbeiten, ohne dass es aber auch gleich ein System der Wissenschaft gibt. Es gibt dann nicht gleich eine Universität. Es gibt da keinen Überbau. Es gibt da keinen... das sind sozusagen, die haben sich alle ihre Berufe erst mal selber erfinden müssen in gewisser Hinsicht. Zeichnet sich denn... also stimmt diese Sicht und wie ...
Ja und nein, ich bin da skeptisch. Ich denke, es hat viel mehr gegeben, als wir kennen. Und ich glaube auch, dass es viel mehr Kommunikation gegeben hat, als wir wissen. Vermutlich eher im wirklichen Gespräch. Dass die sich eben getroffen haben. Wenn es diese große Bibliothek in Alexandria gegeben hat, dann muss die ja von MEnschen genutzt worden sein. Und dann müssen das mehrere gewesen sein. Und dann ist das vermutlich was ähnliches passiert, was auch heute in einer Bibliothek passiert. Man trifft sich, man stellt fest, man hat dieselben Interessen und tauscht sich aus. Und darüber wissen wir wenig. Es muss auch so eine Art Ausbildung gegeben haben, das heißt das Wissen ist vermittelt worden. Wo wir aber eben nicht wissen, wie das funktioniert hat. Und unsere Idee der Universität ist ja etwas, was wir aus dem Mittelalter kennen. Aber ich bin sicher, es hat Vorformen gegeben und ja das sind halt offene Fragen, wo man vielleicht auch noch Spuren findet, aber wir wissen also, dass die Gelehrten, die heute noch überliefert sind, dass die - das nennt man Schüler, das hat nichts zu tun mit der Schule, wie wir heute Schüler denken - sondern sehr lange wurde in der Wissenschaft ein junger Mensch, der bei einem erfahreneren Älteren lernt, der Schüler genannt. und es gibt auch wissenschaftstheoretische Begriffe, die wissenschaftliche Schule und das hat Assozitation mit der Schule, aber auf einer anderen Ebene. Und so was hat es natürlich gegeben. Und es gibt diese Überlieferung von Sokrates und seinen Dialogen, da liegt im Wort schon drin "Dialog", es muss also noch mindestens jemanden gegeben haben.
Ja. Naja wenn man sich das so ein bisschen anschaut, ich meine, die haben natürlich nicht nur jetzt so den ganzen TAg in der Tonne gesessen und vor sich hin philosophiert, sondern hatten natürlich dann auch so ihre eigene Peer-Group um sich herum, die dann quasi dann auch schnell die nächste Generation bekannter Namen herausgebildet hat. Lässt sich denn so zum Ende der Antike dann auch wirklich so ein Wissenschaftssystem erkennen. Also hat sich da schon so etwas dann herausgebildet, was sich aus den Quellen auch wirklich herauslesen lässt?
Na wir haben sehr schöne Manuskripte überliefert, die schon eine relativ geschlossene Darstellung des damals bekannten Wissens beinhalten. Also es gibt astronomische Handschriften, die nach der damaligen Vorstellung also schon die Planeten und das Sonnensystem beschrieben haben und es gibt auch schon einen Vorläufer von Kopernikus, also wo die Erde eben nicht im Zentrum ist, sondern die Sonne, auch das gibt es schon. Es gibt die berühmten Bücher des Euklit, wo wir wissen, dass das also nicht eine Person gewesen sein kann und die aber der Grundstein für die Mathematik sind, weil dort erstmals auch in der Art, wie bis heute Mathematik betrieben wird, von Voraussetzung, Behauptung, Beweis, die Struktur ist dort von den Axiomen, die sind dort. Das heißt es gibt vereinzelte Disziplinen schon einen großen Fundus an Wissen, der in ja wahrscheinlich Jahrtausenden angehäuft wurde, weitergegeben wurde und dann versucht wurde, aufzuschreiben. In dem Bewusstsein, dass es dafür eben wieder weitergegeben werden kann. Und das ist ganz offensichtlich auch ausgetauscht worden. Also die Manuskripte sind eben abgeschrieben worden und in andere Regionen transportiert worden. Das heißt es gab einen Austausch von Wissen und nur deshalb, dank dieser Austauschbeziehungen, haben wir ja solche überlieferten Texte.
Und so das Konzept von Schulen und Universitäten, hat sich das dort schon in irgendeiner Form auch wiedergespiegelt?
Na, es hat ganz sicher auch schon in der Antike Orte gegeben, an denen dieses Wissen weitergegeben wurde. In einer Art, die ähnlich ist, wie wir das auch heute machen. Jemand der keine Ahnung hat, dem versucht man die Grundbegriffe zu erklären und dem versucht man, Stück für Stück das Wissen zu vermitteln. Und sonst wäre es ja auch nicht - sonst hätte es ja einen Bruch gegeben, und die hätten dann irgendwann mal wieder von vorn angefangen.
Ja klar, die Frage ist nur, welche Systematik sozusagen dort an den Tag gelegt wurde.
Ja, es gab natürlich nicht diese strengen Curricula, wie wir sie haben. Und vieles von dem, was in unserem Universitätsbetrieb bekannt ist, ist seit dem Mittelalter. Also die Abschlüsse, einschließlich Bachelor, Master. Das ist dann eine Einrichtung, die im Mittelalter forciert wird und durchgesetzt wird.
Na dann verlassen wir doch mal kurz die Antike und blättern so ein bisschen nach vorne. Ich meine, so in meiner Sicht die Auswirkungen von Wissenschaft zeigt sich im römischen Reich ja ganz stark. Eine Nation, die es geschafft hat, sich enorm im Mittelmeerbereich festzusetzen und die auch fantastische Ingenieursleistungen erbracht hat. Bewässerungssysteme über hunderte von Kilometern, in Dimensionen, wo man sich wirklich fragt, wie das überhaupt möglich gewesen ist, vor allem in Abwesenheit der Maschinentechnik, die wir heute so für selbstverständlich nehmen. War denn bei den Römern denn auch der Wissenschaftsbetrieb auch ein Teil des Systems oder war das eher eine reine Anwendung. Irgendwo muss es ja hergekommen sein.
Na es wird immer behauptet, dass also im Unterschied zu den Griechen und zur Antike, die Römer mehr auf die Praktiken und die Praxisanwendungen orientiert seien und eben weniger Wert auf das, was man Grundlagenfoschung, reine Forschung, wie auch immer, nennen will, Wert gelegt hätten. Das kann man auch nicht so stehen lassen. Sicher in der Mathematikgeschichte gibt es vergleichsweise viel weniger neue Entdeckungen, als in der Zeit davor. Aber in den Anwendungen gibt es halt diese riesen Fortschritte und auch bei dem, was man Verwaltungswissen nennen muss. Denn das römische Reich war ja ein relativ feststrukturiertes Gebilde und die haben als es funktioniert hat, also in den guten Zeiten dieses alten römischen Reiches, haben die ja ein Riesen-Territorium verwaltet. Und haben die ersten Steuersysteme eingerichtet, Rechtssysteme eingerichtet. Also die haben ganz ganz viel Verwaltungswissen angehäuft in der Zeit und das müssen sie auch irgendwo weitergegeben haben. Sprich es muss eine Ausbildung gegeben haben. Es muss eine Ausbildung gegeben haben in, was dann im 18. Jahrhundert, Kameralistik heißt. Also in den Grundlagen, die solche Verwaltungsmenschen benötigen, damit sie das tun können. Es gibt auch natürlich die Beschäftigung mit Astronomie, die ist wichtig, schon alleine für die Seefahrt. Die Navigation erfolgte über die Kenntnis der Sterne. Das ist also auch ein altes Wissen, was weitergegeben wurde und modifiziert wurde. Und gerade in den Sternenbeobachtungen, es gibt immer wieder neue Sternenkataloge, wo immer mehr Sterne aufgenommen werden. Das erforderte gute Augen, weil das Fernrohr ist eine Entwicklung, die viel viel später kommt. Und das erfordert aber auch Akribie und auch eine gewisse Ausbildung, damit man fähig ist, da oben im Gestirn neue Sterne zu entdecken.
Die römische Zeit scheint mir aber nicht so gespickt zu sein mit so großen Namen, wie man sie so aus der Antike schnell vorproduziert.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Woran liegt das? Ich meine, wenn da so viel erfunden worden ist und so viel Wissen geschafft wurde, also ich meine, ich kann mir das überhaupt gar nicht vorstellen, ohne so einen entsprechenden wissenschaftlichen Prozess auch oder kann es sein, dass die Römer da einfach einen ganz andere ARt und Weise der Wissensermittlung und -verbreitung gemacht haben, dass das jetzt nicht so isolierte Berufe waren?
Na es kann einerseits daran liegen, dass wir natürlich immer gerne die nennen, die die ersten waren. Also das ist ja bis heute so. Der erste Astronaut und der erste auf dem Mond und der 2., 3., 4. ist dann auch schon nicht mehr im Gedächtnis. Das kann einer der Gründe sein. Und gerade in der Mathematikgeschichte kommt man eben nicht auf die Idee, die 5. oder 47. Abschrift von Euklits Elementen dann nach dem zu nennen. Sondern das bleibt Euklit. Das ist sicher einer der Gründe, dass wir wengier Namen kennen und dass wir dann nur dann Namen aus der Zeit kennen, wenn etwas neues in dieses System des Wissens eingefügt wird. Also in der Mathematik zum Beispiel Diophantos, mit den diophantischen Gleichungen. Ein Gelehrter aus der Zeit. Und das ist natürlich sowieso das Problem, was unsere Zunft, wir Wissenschaftshistorikerinnen und Wissenschaftshistoriker haben die Benennung nach NAmen ist ja sehr ambivalent. Also erstens ist es nicht immer sicher, dass das wirklich der erste war und zweitens gibt es ja dann immer so die Gefahr des Hagiographischen...
Was heißt das?
Des Hagiographischen?Nna dass man das dann überbetont und dann also auch in der Neuzeit, wenn es dann national betriebene Wissenschaftssysteme gibt, gibt es dann auch sehr unschöne Begleiterscheinungen. Also weil dann jedes Land seinen eigenen Newton oder Leibniz finden will und streitet. Also deshalb ist das immer alles ein bisschen mit Vorsicht zu betrachten.
Ich glaube so die Glühbirne ist entsprechend umstritten, wer die nun eigentlich wirklich erfunden hat.
Ja, das gibt es immer.
Bei den Computern ist das auch ähnlich.
Und ich meine, es macht schon Sinn, weil es macht irgendwas handhabbar, also wenn man erklären will, die Grundlagen der Mathematik, wie sie in den Elementen niedergelegt sind und dann sagt man, Euklit, und mehr oder weniger jeder weiß Bescheid. Aber man muss natürlich auch berücksichtigen, da waren viele beteiligt, deren Namen wir nicht wissen.
Also mit anderen Worten, es muss auch in Rom Wissenschaft gegeben haben. Sie fand offensichtlich statt, weil einfach das MAß an Erkenntnissen, die sich dann eben auch ganz konkret in - ich sage jetzt mal - Ingenieursleistung wiedergespiegelt haben, wäre ohen eine gewisse Grundlagenforschung so auch nicht denkbar gewesen. Der Aquädukt sozusagen.
Ja und wie gesagt, ohne solide Ausbildung auch, ohne die Tradierung wäre es auch nicht möglich gewesen. Das ist ganz wichitg, dass es weitergegeben wird, von Generation zu Generation.
Also bleibt nicht so viel übrig aus der römischen Zeit, was jetzt für die Ausbildung des Wissenschaftssystems relevant gewesen wäre, trotz allem?
Doch, es bleibt einiges. Also zum Beispiel auch, dass man weiß, dass man Wissen weitergeben muss. DASs das als nicht sozusagen etwas angeborenes ist, sondern dass man sich kümmern muss, um Ausbildung, um Bildung. Das ist ein wichtiges Element glaube ich, und auch das Bewusstsein, dass man anknüpft an Vorgänger.
Also das ist vielleicht sozusagen, sind die Römer eher noch ein Beispiel dafür, dass sie es überhaupt erst mal versatnden haben, das systematisch in die Gesellschaft zu tragen.
Na dass sie verstanden haben, dass man Freiräume haben muss, für eine Gruppe, die ntaürlich dann priviligiert war, weil sie nicht diese alltäglichen Arbeiten verrichten musste, dass die das machen. Man muss aber auch gleichzeitig sehen, das galt natürlich nur für die, die keine Sklaven waren, also nur freie Bürger durften, konnten Wissenschaft machen. Die große Gruppe der Sklaven war davon natürlich ausgeschlossen. Das ist auch noch zu berücksichtigen, dass also die Teilhabe an diesem Prozess des Lernens, Bilden, Ausbildens, Wissenschaft betreiben, Wissenschaft formulieren, auf eine sehr kleinen Gruppe beschränkt war.
Was vielleicht auch nicht so eine gute Idee gewesen ist, weil es da sicherlich noch sehr viel mehr Potenzial gegeben haätte.
Ja. Also wir heute würden sagen, da ist ganz viel verschenkt worden an Talenten.
Vielleicht hätte das römische Reich gerettet werden können. Aber nichts hält ewig. Auch die Römer waren irgednawnn nicht mehr die Nummer 1 in Europa, trotz all ihrer Leistungen. Und dann wurde es dunkel irgendwie in Europa, hat man da so ein bisschen den Eindruck.
Ja die Rede vom finsteren Mittelalter. Das stimmt sicher so pauschal auch nicht, aber es wird dann etwas - ich sage mal - unübersichtlicher, weil es gibt diese kleinen Länder und die unterschiedlichen Strukturen. Und es gibt wissenschaftlich verschiebt sich das von Europa in andere Regionen. Und wenn man also in Indien schaut oder China oder die arabischen Länder, dann passieren dort sehr sehr viele Dinge, von denen die Europäer damals nichts wussten. Und man muss sagen, wo bis heute auch Defizite in den Kenntnissen sind. Also Wissenschaftsgeschichte ist viele viele Jahrzehnte sehr europzentristisch betrieben worden. Also das ist so ein Terminus, der beschreibt, dass eben oft nur auf diesen europäischen Teil geguckt wurde und was dort passiert ist und dass mit dem Wissen dann beschrieben wurde, wie die Geschichte der Wissenschaft in all ihren Disziplinen passiert und verlaufen ist. Und wo eben nicht berücksichtigt wurde, was in anderen Regionen passiert ist. Das hat verschiedene Gründe, das hat politische koloniale Gründe, es hat simple Sprachgründe. Wer ist fähig und kann die unterschiedlichen Sprachen lesen. Und es ist dann in den letzten 30-40 Jahren passiert, schon international in der Wissenschaftsgeschichte eine Änderung, dass man sagt, wir müssen weg von diesem eurozentristischen Bild, was wir geschrieben haben, wir, unsere Lehrer oder Urgroßeltern-Lehrer. Und wir müssen anders auf die Geschichte der Wissenschaft gucken. Nun ist mein Spezialgebiet aus verschiedenen Gründen das 19./20. Jahrhundert. Also ich kann hier nur wiedergeben, was ich von Kolleginnen und Kollegen erfahren habe und gelesen habe. Und es gibt ganz ganz viele neue spannende Forschungen zur Geschichte der Wissenschaft in China. Und wir haben in unserem Max-Planck-Institut für Wissenschaftsgeschichte auch eine Abteilung, die sich speziell diesen Fragen widmet, also der Geschichte der Wissensproduktion in China. Die Abteilung ist noch relativ neu. Wir haben Kooperationsbeziehungen mit Beijing, mit der chinesischen Akademie der Wissenschaften, wo es ein Institut für Wissenschaftsgeschichte gibt. Das heißt hier werden in den nächsten Jahren werden ganz viele spannende neue Dinge da passieren. Und in der Kooperation denke ich wird es da sehr viele neue Ereknntnisse geben, die für die Europäer wahrscheinlich überraschend sind, weil sie denken, da gab es also nichts. Und das ist einfach nicht wahr und ähnlich ist das auch mit der Geschichte der Wissenschaften in den arabischen Ländern. Gut in der Mathematikgeschichte, da ist eher bekannt, dass viele dieser griechischen Texte, von denen wir reden, Archimedes oder andere, nur dank der arabischen Wissenschaftler existieren, weil die damals Übersetzungen ins Arabische angefertigt haben und das ist dann nach Europa gebracht worden. Und ist dann also zum Beispiel in wirklich Übersetzerschulen ins Lateinische übersetzt worden. Denn Lateinisch war ganz ganz lang die akzeptierte Wissenschaftssprache. Nun kann man kritisch sagen, das schließt aber viele Menschen aus, Wissenschaft zu betreiben, das ist richtig. Auf der anderen Seite war diese Wissenschaftssprache Latein sehr günstig für die Verständigung untereinander.
Weil es war dann zumindest eine einheitliche Sprache.
Genau, weil es war eine einheitliche Sprache, mit der sich also von Dänemark bis Spanien und von Russland bis Frankreich alle, die Wissenschaft betrieben haben, verständigen konnten. Und alle konnten diese Sprache lesen und ihre Manuskripte in dieser Sprache schreiben, so dass das austauschbar war.
So wie es sich ja heute mit dem Englischen entsprechend entwickelt.
So ist es. Und das hat wirklich auch Vorteile. Es ist eben, man sollte es nicht so nachteilig sehen. also ich höre oft Klagen, ja und dann ist ja alles nur noch in Englisch und bei den internationalen Konferenzen ist ja nur noch Englisch, obwohl oft de jure andere Sprachen möglich wären, aber es ist auch ein großer Vorteil, weil es die Kommunikation erleichtert. Und dass es nun Englisch ist, das hat historische Gründe. Aber ich denke, es ist scohn von Vorteil, also auch unsere Kollege, die am Institut zu Besuch sind aus China, wir reden eben englisch miteinander. Also ich kann kein chinesisch, die können kein deutsch und dank Englisch können wir uns verständigen.
Bleiben wir nochmal kurz so in dieser Phase, also dieser Mittelalterphase, wo Europa so gefühlt so eine kleine Auszeit nimmt. Es gab große Umbrüche und so, aber dann ist einfach das gesamte Gebiet einfach so dermaßen wieder damit beschäftigt, sich gegenseitig zu bekämpfen, dass die eigentlichen wissenschaftlichen Fortschritte woanders stattgefunden haben. China haben wir schon genannt. Und ich denke, das ist ja auch - weiß ich nicht - ich glaube, mir geht es auch ein bisschen so, man hat das Gefühl so, ja Schwarzpulver und so, also da muss ja irgendwas passiert sein, weil das ist ja ansonsten auch überhaupt gar nicht zu erklären, wie diese kulturelle Vielfalt dort auch entstanden ist und auch entsprechende Ingenieursleistung. So was wie die Chinesische Mauer etc., das sind ja alles Dinge, die jetzt ohne wissenschaftlichen Unterbau auch überhaupt gar nicht vorstellbar gewesen wären. Inwiefern, also was hat sich denn dort, also was weiß man denn, was hat sich denn dort entwickelt in dieser Zeit. Und vor allem, was mich besonders interessieren würde, ist es irgendwie anders, als das was sich so im europäischen und vielleicht noch arabischen Raum aufgetan hat.
Also wie gesagt, das ist nicht mein Spezialgebiet.
Ich weiß.
Ich kenne mich da nicht...
Ich frage es trotzdem.
Ich kenne mich da nicht sehr gut aus. Ich weiß, dass zum Beispiel in der Mathematik dort vieles gemacht wurde, ähnlich wie wir das aus der Antike kennen. Und die sind also unabhängig voneinander noch auf die selben Ergebnisse gekommen. Das macht auch Sinn. Also in der Mathematik ist das häufig, dass unabhängig voneinander zu verschiedenen Zeiten in verschiedenen Regionen, dieselben mathematischen Behauptungen entdeckt wurden und dann ähnliche Beweise gemacht wurden. China war ein riesen Reich, was verwaltet wurde, was erfolgreich verwaltet wurde. Ich weiß von Kollegen, die mir von ihren Forschungen erzählten. Man ist dabei inzwischen zu rekonstruieren, wie diese Ausbildung dieser Verwaltungsleute, Verwaltungsbeamten funktioniert hat, wie das gemacht wurde, welche hohen Anforderungen. Und die haben also so eine Art Aufnahmeprüfung durchlaufen müssen und nur wenn sie die bestanden haben, hatten sie dann das Recht da, diese Ausbildung machen zu können. Es fängt damit an, dass die chinesischen Schriftzeichen schwierig sind und man anhand der Kenntnis der Schriftzeichen schon den Bildungsstand sozusagen erkennen kann. Und je mehr Schriftzeichen man kennt, umso höher gebildet ist man. Also damit fängt das eben schon an mit der Ausbildung im Schreiben und dann auch im Rechnen. Und die astronomischen Kenntnisse waren weit entwickelt. Und das ist wieder der Grund, man muss sich orientieren in Zeit und Raum. Und es gibt Austauschbeziehungen zwischen den Ländern, die um China drumrum sind, die gab es natürlich und da spielen viele historische Gründe da eine Rolle, warum die mal besser entwickelt sind und mal schlechter. Und das Wissen, was die Europäer haben von China, das ist dann geschuldet den kirchlichen Missionaren, die also dahinreisen und dann Berichte schreiben, was sie dort erlebt haben und zum Teil eben auch ehrlich schreiben, wie überrascht sie sind, dass das nicht irgendwelche Eingeborenen sind, die nichts können, sondern dass das eine hochentwickelte andere Kultur ist, der sie begegnet sind. Aber auch da, es gibt also ganz ganz viele Berichte von diesen Missionaren, die noch nicht untersucht wurden. Und da gibt es noch ganz ganz viele offene Forschungsfragen und eigentlich müssten ganz viele junge Leute neugierig sein, Chinesisch lernen und sagen, ich will da mitmachen. Weil das für junge Leute leichter ist, chinesisch zu lernen, als für ältere.
Ja und vor allem jetzt, wo auch Englisch sagen wir mal so selbstverständlich wird, auch gerade durch das Internet und die unendlichen Möglichkeiten Englisch aufzunehmen, ist so Chinesisch glaube ich so auch ein bisschen der Prototyp der nächsten Herausforderung, was so Weltsprachenwissen betrifft. Da bin ich auch gespannt.
Ja.
Mir wird sich das nicht mehr erschließen. Jetzt können wir dann mal so ein bisschen in die doch besonders spannende neuere Zeit kommen, wo es ja dann auch in Europa wieder kräftig angezogen hat. Irgendwann war es dann mal vorbei mit dem dunklen Zeitalter und irgendjemand hat das Licht eingeschaltet. Ich weiß nicht, wo kann man denn so festmachen, wo kamen denn die Dinge wieder in die Bewegung. War das dann so Renaissance?
Ja wir sagen ja Renaissance, Wiedergeburt. Also es gibt dann wieder Freiräume. Es gibt die Möglichkeit, dass Personen ihr Auskommen finden, in dem sie "nur" nachdenken und forschen. Und das hat einerseist mit dem Aufschwung der Universitäten zu tun, also die Universitätsgeschichten sind ja etwas sehr spannendes. Weil die Universitäten anfangen, nicht mehr eine reine Bildungsstätte zu sein, die nur das absolut notwendige Minimum Wissen vermittelt und da vor allem natürlich für die Staatsdiener in den jeweiligen Ländern. Ob das die Verwaltungsleute sind, die Mediziner, das ist natürlich ganz wichtig, dass man ausgebildete Mediziner hat, Juristen, Theologen. Aber es gibt dann auch Wissenschaftler, die dann sich den Naturwissenschaften zuwenden können und berühmte Personen sind natürlich Galilei, über den es ja auch ganz viele Bücher gibt und wo man also nachlesen kann, wie er in seiner Zeit verortet die Möglichkeit hatte, dann Wissenschaft zu betreiben und dann eben wirklich einer der Väter der modernen Naturwissenschaft ist und von Galilei stammt ja auch der Satz, die Naturwissenschaften in den Blättern der Mathematik geschrieben werden sollen. Also wo dann auch die Mathematik wieder wichtig wird als Sprache der Naturwissenschaftler sozusagen. Und dann ist wichtig, Galilei Macht eben Experimente. Und die Kunst oder die Kultur des Experimentierens wird wichtig. Man fängt also an, nicht mehr nur Manuskripte zu lesen, Kopien der Manuskripte, Abschriften und dann zu vergleichen, die so und so vielte Abschrift mit der anderen, sondern man fängt an, zu experimentieren.
Das wurde so vorher nicht gemacht?
Also wir vermuten schon, dass das vorher nicht so gemacht wurde. Also das Experimentieren setzen wir schon an, dass das mit der Entwicklung in der frühen Neuzeit beginnt.
Obwohl es schon vorher auch so diese Unterscheidung gab, mit Vermutung, Beweise, ich meine, da muss doch das Experiment dabei sein.
Ja, aber das waren eher so Gedankenexperimente, würden wir sagen, Gedankenexperimente. Aber jetzt wird dann wirklich angefangen. Galilei hat ja mit dem Bau des Fernrohrs wirklich unmittelbar zu tun. Also man versucht dann auch Hilfsinstrumente zu entwickeln, mit denen man besser Wissenschaft untersuchen kann. Und das leuchtet ja jedem ein, wenn ich mit bloßem Auge in den Himmel gucke, sehe ich viel weniger, als wenn ich mein Auge künstlich verstärke mit Hilfe dieses Fernrohrs. Und dann kann ich plötzlich ganz ganz viel mehr entdecken. Und dann beginnt eben diese Geschichte der Fernrohre, bis hin der Superfernrohre, wo heute versucht wird, Spuren fremden Lebens zu finden. Aber da sind eben die Anfänge, dass gesagt wird, ich muss mir eine Experimentalkultur aufbauen, wo ich wirklich etwas beobachten kann und dann kommt ins Spiel, wo ich etwas messen kann. Und dann fängt also die moderne Wissenschaft an, Wert darauf zu legen, ist das beobachtet worden, ist die Beobachtung wiederholbar, sind die Messergebnisse in Florenz, in Berlin, in London vergleichbar. Also das, was ja auch heute ganz wichtig ist, weshalb ja dann zum Glück auch solche Fälschungsgeschichten immer rauskommen, weil das, wenn das eben nicht vergleichbar ist und nicht reproduzierbar ist, wiederholbar ist, dann sind die Zweifel berechtigt, dass die Kollegen entweder simple Fehler machen oder betrügen. Und da passieren natürlich ganz ganz viele neue Entdeckungen, in dem Moment, in dem man also - und es gibt zwei wichitge Instrumente, das Mikroskop, um also immer kleinere Dinge zu finden und das Fernrohr.
Um immer weiter entfernte Dinge zu finden.
Ja und man guckt also in die Ferne, Fernrohr, und man guckt auf die kleinen, und das Mikroskop das ist ganz ganz wichtig, nicht nur für Medizingeschichte, auch für Biologiegeschichte. Und man entdeckt irgendwas und man stellt dann Fragen, was ist das, wie hängt das mit dem zusammen, was ich weiß, widerspricht das dem, was ich weiß. Und das sind also Wissenschaftspraktiken, die dann auch formuliert werden, thematisiert werden.
Und das kann man jetzt an Galileo selbst festmachen oder ist er nur so ein Repräsentant der Zeit, weil sich so ein kompletter Wandel langsam einstellt.
Nein, man kann das an ihm festmachen, an der Art, wie er Wissenschaft betreibt. Und er hat ja selber auch sehr viel geschrieben, also zu Lebzeiten publiziert. Es gibt aber natürlich noch ganz ganz viel Material in dem - also wir nennen das in der Wissenschaftsgeschichte Nachlass, also wenn ein Wissenschaftler, eine Wissenschaftlerin stirbt und ihre Manuskripte, seine Manuskripte bleiben erhalten, dank glücklicher Umstände, dann nennt man das Nachlass - und Florenz hat also ganz ganz viele Manuskripte von Galilei, wo auch immer noch Wissenschaftshistoriker, Kunsthistoriker da Forschungen machen.
Ich bin jetzt ein bisschen überrascht, dass ich nicht erst Leonardo Da Vinci höre, zählt der nicht so richtig als...
Ja doch, aber er ist natürlich für die Mehrzahl der Leute ist er natürlich ein berühmter Maler. Aber bei ihm war natürlich wichtig, dass er geometrische Kenntnisse sich aneignen musste.
Ja aber er war ja ein extremer Universalist, der ja wirklich auch fast alles erfunden hat.
Und dann hat er natürlich genau, er hat ja diese Entwürfe von Flugapparaten und solchen Dingen gemacht. aber er war natürlich eine eher als Wissenschaftler oder auch als Konstrukteur eher eine Person, die relativ einzeln stand. Während um Galilei rum gab es natürlich dann Schüler. Er hat ja auch zeitweilig an der Universität gelehrt und um Galilei rum gab es dann vor allem diese riesen Streitigkeiten mit den Theologen und der katholischen Kirche und das ganze Inquisitionsverfahren, was Auswirkungen hatte, nicht nur für ihn persönlich, sondern auch für alle die, die sich mit dieser neuen Wissenschaft beschäftigten. Inwiefern sie dann in den Konflikt kommen mit der herrschenden Kirchenmeinung.
Da kommen wir glaube ich an einen ganz interessanten Punkt, weil einerseits jetzt Wissenschaft, wenn man jetzt diese ganze Zeit bis hierhin betrachtet so naja, also es war glaube ich relativ klar für jeden so, man hat dann irgendwas herausgefunden, wenn wir das so machen, dann funktioniert das besser und das waren alles recht einfache Dinge, die halt so hier auf der Erde stattfinden, die unmittelbare Auswirkungen haben auf die Ernte, auf den Transport, auf die Navigation. Selbst wenn sie sich in dem Moment schon so ein bisschen mit dem Himmel beschäftigt, aber eben dann auch auf eine sehr mechanische Art und Weise. Galileo dann mit seiner Feststellung, wie wir ja schon gesagt haben, im Prinzip auch schon bei den Ägyptern irgendwo mal gehabt worden ist.
Nein, in der Antike, nicht bei den Ägyptern. In der Antike. Es gibt Aristarch von Samos, der hatte schon mal die Idee, dass die Sonne im Zentrum stehen könnte, im Unterschied zu Ptolemaeus, der die Erde ins Zentrum gesetzt hat.
Okay, aber zumindest gab es bei den Ägyptern schon sehr viele Erkenntnisse aus denen man auch schon vieles hätte ableiten können. Sonnenuhren etc., Berechnungen der Größe der Erde, also es gab ja schon ähnliche Erkenntnisse. Nichts destotrotz ist es jetzt erst mit Galilei an diesen Punkt gekommen, wo sich quasi dieser Status Quo der Weltreligion hier herausgefordert fühlte, weil auf einmal die Wissenschaft es quasi gewagt hat, mehr als jetzt nur praktische Erkenntnisse für das tägliche Leben zu liefern, sondern eben auch das Weltbild begann zu definieren.
Na es gibt eine schöne Szene in Berthold Brechts "Leben des Galilei, wo Brecht den Anhängern Galileis sagt, dass die Kirche jetzt so streng einschreitet liegt daran, die Wissenschaft ist unters Volk gekommen. Da ist was wahres dran, in dem Moment, wo es nicht nur eine kleine elitäre Gruppe ist, die sich mit solchen Ideen, Weltbildern beschäftigt. Solange das eine kleine Gruppe ist, hatte die kirchliche Institution keine Sorgen, weil es rüttelte nicht an ihrer Machtstellung. Es ging natürlich um Macht. Aber wenn der Kreis größer wird, weil ich habe Universitäten, ich habe einfach zahlenmäßig eine größere Gruppe, die sich Wissenschaft zuwendet. Ich habe neue Berufsmöglichkeiten für ausgebildete im Handwerk, in der Ingenieurkunst, im Schiffbau, in der Navigation. Dann ist natürlich die Gefahr der Machtsicherung eher gegeben. Wenn es also viel mehr Skeptiker, Zweifler gibt, denn mit diesem, die Erde ist im Zentrum, darum verband sich ja dann der kirchliche Anspruch, die Institution des wahren und einzig wahren zu sein. Und dadurch kommen die Konflikte. Weil dann Galilei verstellvertretend ist für Ketzer, Heretiker und deshalb reagiert dann die Kirche so. Und Kopernikus als Mann der Kirche. Er war ja ein Mönch gewesen. Der hatte natürlich große Befürchtungen. Und insofern hat das ein bisschen zu tun, dass Wissenschaft mehr in die Öffentlichkeit kommt und mehr rezipiert wird, weil sie auch mehr gebraucht wird. Also ich brauche eben mehr wissenschaftliche Kenntnisse für bestimmte neue Berufe.
Wie ging es dann von da aus weiter. Weil irgendwann - ich meine, wir stehen jetzt ja auch so in den letzten Jahrhunderten vor der industriellen Revolution, die ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch eine wissenschaftliche Revolution war, weil die Wissenschaft überhaupt erst die Erkenntnisdichte geschafft hat, um dann eben auch einmal die gesamtgesellschaftlichen Bedingungen revolutionär zu ändern.
Ja die industrielle Revolution hat da auch Folgen für die Universitäten. Es müssen einfach mehr Leute ausgebildet werden. Also auf der einen Seite, man schafft den Freiraum, dass es Leute gibt, die professionell wissenschaftlich geprägte Berufe ausüben können und man braucht umgekehrt mehr, die das können. Das ist ja dann so ein Wechselspiel. Und damit wird die Ausbildung wichtiger und damit gibt es dann auch Überlegungen, dass man die Ausbildung strukturiert, dass man Prüfungen einführt, also Examen, dass das dann irgendwo sichtbar wird. Da ist gerade in Deutschland ist dieser Dr. Ing. auf den die Ingenieure bis heute stolz sind, das war dann schon eine wichtige Innovation, dass man festlegt, welche Bedingungen erfüllt sein müssen. Welches Wissen müssen die haben, um diesen Dr. Ing. dann wirklich zu haben. Und das passiert in den Ländern auf unterschiedliche Weise und hat jeweils zu tun mit der schlicht der ökonomischen Kraft. Weil Bildung kostet Geld. Und Bildung ist lange vor allem privat finanziert worden. Das heißt es gab dann die Kluft, wo die Eltern Bildung für die Kinder finanzieren können und Eltern, die es nicht können. Aber es gibt auch immer schon dann den Versuch der Stipendien. Das also aufzufangen durch private Stiftungen, die Stipendien gewähren. Oder durch den Landesherrn, also der berühmte Mathematiker Gauss hatte dann eben ein Stipendium von seinem Landesherrn, der das Studium finanzierte. Also das gab es auch immer, es gab immer die Versuche, diese privatrechtliche Regelung, es muss bezahlt werden, es müssen die Eltern, die Familie bezahlen, zu ergänzen für begabte. Und das ist aber eben immer sehr unterschiedlich dann gehandhabt worden.
Wann ist es denn von dem Mäzenatentum wirklich in so ein, wir müssen das jetzt quasi als gesamtgesellschaftliche Aufgabe verstehen übergegangen?
Das ist in den einzelnen Ländern unterschiedlich. Also es gibt viele Länder, die dem Staat das nicht allein überlassen wollten, die bewusst erklärten, das muss er über diese Mäzene, Mäzenatentum passieren. Und es ist ja interessant Mezänatentum ist ja sehr ambivalent. Und ich habe vor ein paar Jahren mal ein Seminar gemacht an der Humboldt-Universität über Geschichte Mäzenatentum und ich war eigentlich enttäuscht, - ich hatte ungefähr 20-24 Studenten im Seminar und ich hatte das versucht zu machen an Wissenschaftsgeschichte und Kunstgeschichte und ich war eigentlich enttäuscht, dass fast alle meine Studenten das nur negativ sahen. Und also immer erklärt haben, ja aber der Mäzen der gibt das Geld und dann will der darüber bestimmen und will sich einmischen. Und wenn ich dann gesagt habe, wir haben aber die und die und die Beispiele, wo das Geld wirklich gegeben wurde, in dem Erkennen, ich habe zu viel Geld und das ist gut aufgehoben in der Wissenschaft oder in der Kunst, dann haben die mich immer so zweifelnd angeguckt und ich fand das schade, dass es also nur negativ konnotiert ist. Und das ist aber glaube ich etwas, was in Deutschland vor allem verbreitet ist.
Wollte ich auch grad sagen.
Was in den USA und Großbritannien auf keinen Fall so ist, es hat in Deutschland dann natürlich auch zu tun mit der Nazizeit, weil zwischen 1870 und 1933 viele jüdische Industrielle gestiftet und gespendet haben und deren Stiftung dann also 33 entweder kaputt gemacht wurden oder totgelegt wurden. Und da war das wirklich idealistisches Spenden und dieser Idealismus ist leider als Motiv wird der nicht gesehen und der ist aber wichtig, also natürlich es gibt auch die Beispiele, wo einer sagt, ich will, dass das Gebäude nach mir benannt wird und der Lehrstuhl nach mir aus offensichtlichen Gründen, aber man sollte nicht bei all diesen Dingen unterstellen, dass das immer so wäre.
Ja selbst wenn, ich meine, das ist ja noch der geringste Preis, den man da bezahlen kann. Schwieriger wäre es halt, wenn jetzt jemand Geld nur gibt, um eine bestimmte Sicht..
Um bestimmte Forschung, genau.
... eine bestimmte Sicht zu unterstützen, und wenn die Ergebnisse was anderes bringen, dann wird es wieder sein gelassen etc. Das ist ja eigentlich die Gefahr.
Genua, und aber wie gesagt, insofern ist das schade, dass in Deutschland also so fast nur negativ auf diese Möglichkeit geguckt wird. Es hat sich in den letzten zehn Jahren ein bisschen gebessert, auch einfach, weil es inzwischen mehr private Stiftungen und Gründungen gibt. Aber es ist schon schade. Weil dieses Mäzenatentum war ein wichtiges Moment zum Füllen von Gerechtigkeitslücken, gerade was Bildung, Ausbildung betraf und auch was die Finanzierung von Forschung betraf, weil natürlich je mehr wir in die Neuzeit kommen, umso teurer werden diese Experimentalanlagen. Also um 1900 konnte man Chemikerinnen noch empfehlen, studieren Sie Chemie, Sie brauchen keine Anstellung in der Industrie, Sie können Auftragsforschung in Ihrer Küche machen. Das könnte man heute natürlich nicht. Weil also das und gerade das, was wir unter Lebensmittelchemie verstehen, Untersuchungen, das haben die damals gemacht und hatten ihr Auskommen und konnten als Chemikerinnen arbeiten, da ging das mit der Küche noch. Das geht heute nicht.
Ja die Küche erfüllt ja in der Regel keine Reinraumbedingung.
Und Wissenschaft ist also parziell so teuer, dass dann nach Möglichkeiten gesucht werden muss, sie zu unterstützen. Wobei auch das natürlich Aushandelsprozesse sind, wie viel anteiliges Geld will ein Staat oder eine Gesellschaft in Bildung, Ausbildung, Forschung stecken. Man wird verstehen, die Zuhörer werden verstehen, dass ich als Wissenschaftlerin sage, es kann nie genug sein. Je mehr Geld, umso besser. Und ich könnte eben aus der Wissenschaftsgeschichte dann auch die Beispiele anführen, wo das - weil Wissenschaftshistorikerinnen, Wissenschaftshistoriker können nicht sagen, was heute gemacht werden soll, aber wir haben genug Negativbeispiele, wie es schief geht und wie man es nicht machen soll.
Dann mal her mit den Beispielen, das würde mich ja jetzt doch sehr interessieren. Was sind denn so die Fälle, an denen man das Für und Wider gut festmachen kann?
Na wir hatten Galilei und wir hatten den Prozess der Inquisition. Das ist also ein Beispiel, was ziemlich deutlich zeigt, solche Eingriffe von außen, in dem Falle also die katholische Kirche als Machtinstrument, behindern Wissenschaft.
Ja das ist klar, aber wenn es jetzt konkret zum Beispiel um die Finanzierung geht.
Und wir können sehen, dass zu Galileis Zeiten, er war ja dann in Florenz und die Medici waren ja, wenn man will, der Mäzen. Was also sehr gut war, denn wenn die das nicht gemacht hätten, dann hätte er vielleicht irgendwo nur so einen Brotberuf haben können und einen Lehrberuf und vieles von dem, was er entdeckt und aufgeschrieben hat, hätte er nicht aufschreiben können. Oder es gibt das Beispiel der École Polytechnique in Paris in Frankreich, nach der Revolution 1789, wo zielgerichtet die Ausbildung verbessert wurde und Napoleon ist nun nicht unbedingt eine positive Figur in der europäischen Geschichte mit seinen Eroberungskriegen, aber Napoleon hat erklärt, ein Staat, der die Mathematik nicht wertschätzt, hat keine Chance in einer Auseinandersetzung. Und man sieht, dass also da ganz viel Wert gelegt wurde auf eine absolut solide mathematische Grundausbildung und die École Polytechnique war Vorbild für die deutschen politechnischen Hochschulen. Mit dieser breiten Ausbildung an - wir würden heute sagen - Basiswissen oder Grundlagenwissen und eben erst später die Spezailisierung. Und da war eben die Erkenntnis für viele Ingenieursberufe, Physik, Chemie ist eine mathematische Grundausbildung wichtig.
Wenn man jetzt Napoleon hört, denkt man natürlich auch gleich an die ganzen Kriege, die der junge Mann alle so angezettelt hat, das ist ja dann sicherlich auch ein Teil der Motivation gewesen, auch die militärische Forschung voranzubringen.
Ja sicher, das ist die Ambivalenz von Naturwissenschaft. Und dass ich natürlich fast jede dieser naturwissenschaftlichen Entwicklungen auch missbrauchen kann. Aber das geht auch schon mit dem Fernrohr los, also mit dem Fernrohr, das Galilei benutzt hat, um die Jupitermonde zu beobachten, in den Händen der Militärs ist das hervorragend geeignet, um auf See den Schiffsgegner eher zu entdecken und dadurch Chancen zu bekommen. Alle diese Entwicklungen sind ambivalent und alle diese Entwicklungen können vom Militär missbraucht werden.
Dual Use nennt man das heutzutage.
Jaja.
Aber ist ja auch überhaupt nicht zu verhindern.
Es ist wenn überhaupt ist zu verhindern, dass die Gesellschaften sich durchsetzen und sagen, wir wollen keine Kriege. Wir wollen so wenig Rüstung wie möglich und wir wollen keine kriegerischen Auseinandersetzungen. Im 21. Jahrhundert wäre das eigentlich eine berechtigte Forderung, aber wenn man sich umguckt, sich es zur Zeit nicht so aus.
Nein ist grad bisschen...
Ist grad ein bisschen umgekehrt.
Ja bisschen unpopulär.
Also der Rüstungsetat soll erhöht werden, hat der Gipfel in Walse erklärt, was also höchst bedenklich ist. Weil eigentlich müsste, könnte man es versuchen, mit friedlichen Mitteln zu lösen, die Konflikte.
Aber da stehen dann die Einzelinteressen häufig auch wieder im Weg.
Ja und da ist natürlich für Wissenschaftler, Naturwissenschaftler immer die Diskrepanz.
Ich denke, Galileo Galilei dürfte sich nicht so sehr viel Gedanken darüber gemacht haben, was jetzt die Erfindung des Fernrohrs so an Menschenleben im Kriegseinsatz gekostet hat. Jetzt allerdings - ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt schon bei Napoleon eine nennenswerte Rolle gespielt hat, Waffentechnik wird sicherlich ein Teil dessen gewesen sein. Aber umso mehr wir uns jetzt hier der Neuzeit nähern, ist das aber schon sehr wohl eine Frage. Wir hatten ja schon eingangs erwähnt, für den Wissenschaftler ist nicht unbedingt immer nur entscheidend, wie er arbeitet, sondern auch welche ethischen Prinzipien dem zu Grunde liegen. Wann hat sich denn so die ethische Frage dann auch wirklich mal bewusst ergeben. Seit wann wird so etwas überhaupt diskutiert?
Na wir müssen noch einen Schritt zurückgehen. In Europa passiert es dann, dass so etwa ab dem 19. Jahrhundert Wissenschaft sehr national organisiert wird. Also während es im 12./13./14. Jahrhundert noch nicht dies Schranken gab und Medizinstudenten also wirklich in Europa von Universität zu Universität gingen. Wird es im 19. Jahrhundert zunehmend national betrieben. Es gibt immer noch die Studienaufenthalte im Ausland, aber die Abschlüsse werden sozusagen nur noch zu Hause gemacht. Also für Franzosen in Frankreich und für Deutsche in den deutschen Ländern, da ist ja nochmal das förderale Prinzip und in Russland in Russland. Oder in Großbrittanien in Großbrittanien. Und es beginnt ein Wettbewerb, so ein nationaler Wettbewerb, also solche Diskurse "ist Cambridge University in UK besser als München oder Berlin?" die finden wir auch da schon mal. Wo dann, vor allem wenn die Professoren mehr Geld wollen, wird dann natürlich argumentiert, aber wir liegen zurück im Vergleich zu Frankreich oder Großbritannien und wir brauchen mehr Zuwendungen und mehr Lehrstühle und mehr Laboratorien und mehr Institute. Und das ist aber nicht nur so eine Retork, um mehr Geld zu bekommen, da passieren wirklich solche Wettbewerbe und solche eher national organisierten Strukturen. Und das wird dann aber versucht von den Wissenschaftlern aufzufangen, indem es internationale Kongresse gibt. Also man könnte sehr schön eine ganze Vorlesung halten über die Geschichte internationaler Kongresse in den einzelnen Disziplinen, die immer diese Ambivalenz im Hintergrund haben. Nationale Sozialisation und Ausbildung, aber gleichzeitig versteht man sich als Physiker, also Physikerinnen kommen da leider erst ab 1900 vor. Aber man versteht sich als Physiker, der einer internationalen Gruppe von Physikern angehört. Und diese Ambivalenz und dieses einerseits und andererseits das geht faktisch bis Ausbruch des Ersten Weltkrieges und die erste große Krise ist dann 1914 in allen beteiligten Ländern. Das also bis zum Ausbruch des Weltkrieges man sich als Republique de le Lettre oder Scientific Community als internationale Fachgruppe verstand und plötzlich national agiert. Und der Erste Weltkrieg ist auch der erste Krieg, wo Wissenschaft eine große Rolle spielt, im Sinne von Entwicklung neuer schrecklicherer Waffen. Und weil Sie nach der ethischen Dimension gefragt haben, das wird mit dem Einsatz der Chemiewaffen, des Giftgaseinsatzes da wird es das erste Mal, dann nach 1918 thematisiert und problematisiert. Und das ist schon ein gewisser Bruch dessen, was man bis dahin für vernünftig oder noch machbar hielt. Und dieser Giftgaseinsatz verändert gravierend das Verständnis von Wissenschaftlern. Dass sie als nicht nur eine schnelere und bessere Waffe entwickelt haben, sondern etwas völlig anderes, in einer Dimension, wo man also viel mehr Menschen umbringt, unschuldige Menschen umbringt. Und sie haben dann in den 1920er Jahren eine große Bewegung der Ächtung dieser Chemiewaffen. Wo auch Wissenschaftler teilnehmen. Es gibt eine Schweizer Chemikerin, Gertrud Woker, die ist heute fast vergessen. Gertrud Woker ist dann eine, die auch Konferenzen organisiert europaweit und die versucht so eine Art Manifest durchzusetzen, dass die Chemiker sich weigern, nochmal chemische Waffen einzusetzen. Und wenn Sie wollen ist das ähnlich, wie dann nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg und dem Einsatz der Atombomben auf Hiroshima und Nagasaki, wo ja ganz viele Physiker und die Pakwish???-Bewegung versuchen, so ein Moratorium durchzusetzen. Also wir Physiker haben das jetzt entwickelt, gebaut, aber wir appelieren, es nie einzusetzen. Und da sehen Sie auch, dass eine Zeit lang, die Öffentlichkeit gerade in den 1960er/70er Jahren sehr aufmerksam gehört hat, dass was die Physiker sagen, in vielen Ländern. Und dass das also eine Waffe ist, die man nicht einsetzen darf, weil dann die Erde aufs Spiel gesetzt wird.
Aber die Wissenschaft selber hat ja dadurch dann so ein bisschen auch ihre Unschuld verloren. Also bis dahin hatte man immer so diesen ewigen Fortschritt, es geht immer weiter. Die Zukunft ist unser bester Freund und egal was wir machen, also wir können soviel forschen wie wir wollen, es kann sich nur positiv auswirken und das ist ja im Prinzip ein kompletter Rückschritt in der Hinsicht.
Ja, weil aber ich glaube, weil eben diese Destruktionskräfte so groß waren. Also so ein Einsatz mit Giftgas ist eben so verheerend und trifft so viele Unschuldige und ähnlich der Einsatz einer Atombombe, dass da also das was man für noch akzeptabel in kriegerischen Auseinandersetzungen hielt war also durchbrochen worden. Und gerade dann die Hochrüstung während des Kalten Krieges hat ja dazu geführt, dass - also wir haben ja unglaubliches Glück gehabt, also ich sage immer, wir hatten unglaubliches Glück, dass nichts passiert ist bis 1989, weil ja nachher, auch aufgrund dieser Modernisierung der Raketen und wie schnell die da eingeschlagen hätten. Es waren ja dann nur noch fünf Minuten, um gegenseitig zu sagen, sorry das war ein Irrtum. Und insofern hat die Menschheit einfach nur Glück gehabt, dass es nicht zur Auslöschung gekommen ist. Denn das vorhandene Potenzial hätte ja gereicht x-fach alles Leben auf der Erde zu zerstören. Und ich glaube wegen dieser Dimension waren dann auch alle so erschrocken. Und die Physiker hatten ja dann auch keinen Einfluss mehr. Also es gibt ja die Berichte von denen, die am Manhattan Project beteiligt waren. Und es gibt um James Frank übrgins, den ich vorhin ja schon mal erwähnt habe, um James Frank herum gab es ja eine Gruppe von Physikern, die dann die Hoffnung hatten, nachdem also Nazideutschland bedingungslos kapituliert hat und diese Bedrohung, dass die Nazis die Bombe gehabt hätten, ja nicht mehr war. Dann gab es Appelle an das US-Militär eben diese Bombe nicht einzusetzen in Japan und dann haben die sich ja drüber hinweggesetzt und es gab für viele Beteiligte einen Schock. Weil sie das natürlich so auch nicht gewollt haben. Weil sie unter anderen Bedingungen für das Manhattan Project sich bereit erklärt haben. Und dann gesehen haben, sie haben als Physiker aber keinen Einfluss, dass sich jetzt die Situation geändert hat.
Da sind wir wieder beim Zauberlehrling. Die Geister, die ich rief.
Ja. Und insofern, man sollte da schon gucken, auch gerade die Geschichte des Kalten Krieges und die Beteiligung der Wissenschaftler. Wissenschaft ist natürlich dann, wenn sie in der Lage ist, solche destruktiven Waffen zu entwickeln und die Grundlagen zu liefern, sind Wissenschaftler in einer hohen Verantwortung, die ihnen aber oft nicht gegeben wird und gelassen wird. Also in dem Moment, wo das in den Händen der Militärs ist, müssen andere Kräfte in der Gesellschaft mitagieren und sagen, aber abstrakt zur Abschreckung ja, aber nie im Einsatz und das muss ausgehandelt werden. Und das muss in einer Gesellschaft auch diskutiert werden und da sind jetzt nicht die Wissenschaftler die "allein schuldigen", da trägt schon die Gesellschaft insgesamt Verantwortung dafür, ob das mit Augenmaß betrachtet wird oder ob dann die Entscheidungsträger plötzlich Leute sind, die nicht mal richtig wisse, was da passiert, wenn sie so einen Knopf drücken.
Findet denn diese ethische Debatte in der Ausbildung heutzutage auch an den Universitäten auch mit statt? Gibt es diese Auseinandersetzung?
Eigentlich kaum. Also das ist ein interessantes Phänomen, das Ende des Kalten Krieges ist ja noch nicht so lange her. Also sagen wir 1990/91, dann sind das ja mal gerade 25 Jahre und es wird merkwürdigerweise nicht thematisiert. Es ist für die jungen Leute soweit weg, als unsere Geschichte über Galilei. Also sozusagen das Konfliktdrama hat der Physiker im Kalten Krieg, denken wir zum Beispiel an Sacharov in der Sowjetunion, das ist soweit weg, wie Galileo und die Inquisition.
Kann man aber trotzdem noch was draus lernen, so ist es ja nicht.
Ja natürlich, ja natürlich, da kommen wir zurück, was ich am Anfang gesagt habe, ich würde es wunderbar finden, wenn Wissenschaftsgeschichte ein Teil der Grundausbildung wird von allen Fächern, von Archäologie bis Zoologie und genau da ist der Raum, so etwas zu thematisieren und ein Bewusstsein dafür zu wecken.
Also nicht nur, aber auch aus ethischen Gründen.
Ja und nein. Also auf der einen Seite haben wir schon beachtliche Erfolge, also das Wissenschaftssystem in dem Sinne gibt es ja nicht. In den europäischen Ländern sind die Systeme immer noch sehr unterschiedlich, aber etwas verallgemeinert kann man sagen, die Wissenschaftssysteme basieren auf drei Säulen und das ist einmal die ganze schulische Ausbildung, die zum Teil unterschiedlich, also in Deutschland dann mit dem Abitur und in anderen Ländern ist es ein bisschen flexibler und dann gibt es die technischen Hochschulen oder Universitäten und die Universitäten, die die akademische Ausbildung tragen und die sozusagen die sind, die dafür sorgen, dass es in vielen Bereichen genormte Abschlüsse gibt, wo man mit einer hohen Wahrscheinlichkeit davon ausgehen kann, ein Ingenieur, der ein Diplom hat ist eben von Kiel bis München hat der die ähnliche Ausbildung und dann im Zuge der europäischen Einigungsprozesse hofft man ja, dass das auch irgendwann von Aarhus bis Marseille glt. Und dann ist die dritte Gruppe die Grundlagenforschung, reine Forschung, also diese wissenschaftlichen Institute, wo wir ja in Deutschland mehrere Organisationen haben, die Helmholtz-Gemeinschaft, Max-Planck-Gesellschaft, die Leibniz-Gemeinschaft, wo es in Frankreich das Senaes??? gibt. Wo es in Spanien so eine ähnliche Institution wie Senaes??? gibt. Daneben ist noch die Forschung, die in der Industrie gemacht wird. Die da auch noch dazu gehört und es gibt ja auch die Bestrebung, europäische Programme aufzulegen, wo dann wirklich Forscher kooperieren können - sagen wir - aus Frankreich, aus Deutschland und aus der tschechischen Republik meinetwegen. Das gibt es alles und das ist unterschiedlich umgesetzt und ich würde sagen, man kann da noch viel mehr machen. Man kann auch diesen Fond in der europäischne Union vergrößern oder man muss ihn vergrößern. Man muss es entbürokratisieren. Es ist zum Teil mit sehr aufwendigen Verfahren verbunden. Es gibt glaube ich schon so einen Konsens, dass Wissenschaft dazugehört. Und der Streit geht dann eher darüber, weil viele Leute nicht wissen, was da in den Forschungsinstituten passiert. Also unsere Max-Planck-Gesellschaft wir machen so was öfter mal Tag der offenen Tür und dann können Besucher die Institute angucken und können mal sehen, was da passiert und was da gemacht wird. Das halte ich für eine ganz gute Idee, um Akzeptanz zu erzielen. Es muss mehr passieren, dass junge Leute Spaß haben, Wissenschaftler zu werden. Da muss aber umgekehrt im deutschen System auch eine andere Nachhaltigkeit und Stetigkeit an Stellen geschaffen werden, was wieder Geld kostet. Also wir haben einfach zu viele befristete Stellen und zu wenig unbefristete Stellen, im Vergleich zu Großbrittannien und Frankreich sind wir da viel schlechter aufgestellt. Und das wir ein zunehmendes Problem bei den jungen Leuten, weil die wollen dann einfach nicht unter diesen Bedingungen, wie ein moderner Nomade von Wissenschaftslabor zu Wissenschafstlabor wandern, weil irgendwann möchte man Familie und möchte das vereinbaren und es ist ja nicht wahr, dass Wissenschaft 24 Stunden am Tag gemacht werden muss. Oder dieses alte Mönchsmodell, eine Frau stört die Wissenschaft. Ein Wissenschaftler muss alleine bleiben. Das ist ja alles nicht wahr. Und für die modernen Verhältnisse muss ich dann auch adäquate Möglichkeiten finden. Und es wird mit Recht seit Jahren gedrängt, dass mehr Wissenschaftlerinnen in diese Berufe kommen. Wissenschaftlerinnen haben dann ein noch größeres Problem, diese Familienplanung zu vereinbaren mit dem Nomadenstatus zwei Jahre hier, zwei Jahre dort, zwei Jahre da. Also da muss sich einfach etwas ändern. Da muss einfach mehr Flexibilität auch rein. Wissenschaft ist eben kein Beamtenjob, auch wenn wir in der Geschichte der Akademien so eine schöne Kreation hatten, so um 1900 hießen die Wissenschaftler, die wenige unbefristete Stellen in den Akademieprojekten hatte, die hießen wirklich wissenschaftlicher Beamter. Und das Modell ist eben nicht geeignet, also ich denke, man muss da wirklich flexibler sein und muss schauen, was in anderen europäischen Ländern gemacht wird und was da wirklich läuft. Es gibt die Klagen in der Universität, dass wir zu wenig, also die Juniorprofessur ist ja nur befristet und nur wenige haben dann die Chance, dass das tenure track wird, also eine unbefristete und da muss einfach mehr passieren. Damit die jungen Leute nicht sozusagen denken, sie haben keine Chancen. Weil wir brauchen die begabtesten in den Universitäten und in den Forschungsinstituten.
Jetzt hatten wir vorhin ja schon über das Mäzenatentum gesprochen, auch der währenden Debatte, ob das jetzt so eine gute Idee war oder nicht, aber so war es auf jeden Fall, also ursprünglich war das eben quasi die reichen Familien und damals hatte die Gesellschaft ja auch super extreme Unterschiede zwischen arm und reich. Es gab immer diese starken Familienverbände oder in dem Sinne auch wirtschaftlichen Verbände, die da letzten Endes darstellten und aus diesem Geld heraus, wie ja früher auch schon bei den Königen und anderen Herrschern, die sich dann halt immer so ein bisschen so ihre Hofnarrenwissenschaftler gehalten haben.
Die sich eine Akademie hielten.
Ja oder eine eigene Akademie hielten, um ihren eigenen Namen drauf zu machen. Jetzt haben wir das in der modernen Zeit die Wissenschaft dann immer weiter popularisiert hat und auch immer mehr zu einem festen Bestandteil der Gesellschaft gemacht hat, ist es ja quasi mehr, nicht nur in die Gesellschaft, sondern auch in den Staat reingerückt. Es ist ein Selbstverständnis gekommen, dass man kostenlose Ausbildung anbieten muss oder überhaupt erschwingliche - inwiefern das kostenlos, das lässt sich sicherlich nochmal debattieren - aber dass es sozusagen einfach gemacht werden muss, dass man nicht auch bewusst eine Barriere aufzieht mit, so hier bitte nur die Elite und der Rest dann bitte nach links gehen. Ich denke es gibt schon das Selbstverstnädnis mittlerweile, zumindest jetzt im europäischen Kontext, über den wir ja im Prinzip hier die ganze Zeit reden, dass das im Prinzip richtig ist. Trotz alledem merkt man ja auch, wie die wirtschaftlichen Anforderungen in den letzten Jahrzehnten auch stark wieder zurückgewirkt haben. Wissenschaftler müssen sich selber um Drittmittel kümmern, teilweise auch in erheblichem Maße. Werden auch in ihrer Arbeit danach beurteilt, wie viel Drittmittel sie denn jetzt einwerben. Wo man sich dann halt auch wieder fragt, worum geht es jetzt eigentlich? Also geht es jetzt darum, die Geldmaschine am Laufen zu halten oder geht es auch irgendwie um die eigentliche Arbeit. Spielt das dann an der Stelle überhaupt noch eine Rolle. Das ist so das eine was ich sehe. Das andere ist natürlich auch was so die Ausbildung, die erste Ausbildung an sich betrifft. Also auch die verkürzten Studienzeiten folgen ja im Prinzip auch so dieser Logik mit, naja dieses System muss halt schneller zumindest halbwegs brauchbar ausgebildete Mitarbeiter erzeugen. Wo befinden wir uns jetzt sozusagen auf diese Weg. Sind wir jetzt wieder sozusagen durch die Hintertür wieder auf dem Weg zum Mäzenatentum oder ist das jetzt etwas übertrieben dargestellt?
Also im besten Falle sind wir noch in der Versuchsphase. Aber es ist immer schlecht, weil ja da Menschen involviert sind in solche Versuche. Die Finanzierung ist ein echtes Problem und die Universitäten sind seit Jahren unterfinanziert und ich sehe nirgends den Willen, staatlicherseits das zu ändern. Wobei ich ablehne diese Formulierung, es ist kein Geld da. Also wir führen das Interview in Berlin und wir müssen nur ein paar Kilometer weiter gucken, dieses sogenannte Schönefeld-neu, da sind vier Milliarden im märkischen Sand gesetzt inzwischen, vier Milliarden und das könnte man nun umrechnen, was man da alles machen könnte. Wie viele unbefristete Stellen, wie viel Laborausstattungen, wie viel Verbesserung in Lehre und Forschung.
Na gut, aber das ist ja eine lokale politische Debatte.
Ja gut, aber die Hamburger haben ihre Elbphilharmonie und in Stuttgart haben sie dieses dusselige Bahnprojekt. Dieses, wir haben kein Geld, ist ein Argument, was Kritiker zum Schweigen bringen soll und ich wundere mich, dass die sich immer zum Schweigen bringen lassen. Es muss natürlich ausgehandelt werden, es ist eine politische Entscheidung letztlich, ob das Geld eben da im märkischen Sand oder in die Elbe oder sonstwo hingeschmissen wird. Oder stattdessen nachhaltig sinnvoller ausgegeben wird. Man kann es - zur Zeit ist ja dann immer die Hoffnung, es finden sich Mäzene, es findet sich irgendeine Familie, die irgendwas geerbt hat. Es geistern ja auch in der Presse Zahlen, wie viele Bundesbürger demnächst ganz reiche Erbschaften antreten werden. Und dann wird gehofft, dass die nun ein paar Lücken füllen, ein paar Löcher stopfen. Mäzenatentum ist gut als ergänzende Finanzierung. Aber wenn wir uns einbilden, dass wir in nächster Zukunft damit Strukturprobleme lösen können, dann ist das natürlich falsch. Und es gibt eine Reihe von Strukturproblemen und es gibt bei der Einführung von Bachelor und Master und der Verschlankung des Studiums sehr sehr viele hausgemachte Fehler, auch in den einzelnen Fächern. Also wenn ich mir angucke, dass es selbst Diskrepanzen unter Mathematikern gibt, was das Minimum ist dessen, was die von Hamburg bis München in dem Bachelorstudium haben müssen, dann ist das einfach schlimm und dann muss da auch nachverhandelt und nachjustiert werden, weil es zur Zeit nicht sehr günstig läuft.
Aber was sind denn die Bereiche, die sozusagen unterfinanziert sind. Also was lässt denn das Wissenschaftssystem in der derzeitigen Ausprägung suboptimal funktionieren?
Es fängt an, dass eine ganze Reihe von Gebäuden saniert werden müssen. Also die FU hat geklagt mit Recht, sie war in der Exzellenzinitiative zweimal vorn, aber es gibt nicht genug Geld, um einfach die Gebäude zu sanieren, die eben nach 40-50 Jahren mal saniert werden müssen. In Berlin in den Schulen werden die Eltern gebeten, die Klassenzimmer zu malern, weil kein Geld da ist. Also es fängt mit solchen trivialen Sachen an. dass da einfach angeblich kein Geld da ist, um ein Minimum an dessen was jeder der irgendwo wohnt weiß, dass hin und wieder gemalert werden muss und hin und wieder saniert werden muss. Und das ist immer eben aufgestaut und auch das weiß man aus den individuellen Erfahrungen, wenn ich so was verzögere, wird der Schaden größer und die Kosten werden höher. Also das ist das eine Problem, wo schlicht Geld fehlt. Das andere Problem ist, dass nicht genug die Lehre investiert wird und in Lehrkräfte, die eben nicht nur zwei Jahre da sind, sondern denen die Möglichkeit über längerfristige Stellen gegeben werden muss, damit die Lehre verbessert werden kann. Weil die dann die Erfahrung haben und die können das dann besser machen als jemand, der mal ein Jahr da hinkommt und wieder weg und wieder neu. Und da kann sicherlich dann einiges auch in den Bachelor-, Masterstudien besser werden, wenn ich da mehr und bessere Lehrkräfte habe. Also wenn Sie lesen in manchen - ein Seminar mit 50 Leuten ist kein Seminar mehr. Wenn Sie mehr Erfahrung haben, können Sie das auffangen, indem Sie so eine Art Vorlesung machen und anschließend noch Sprechstunde anbieten. Aber das eigentliche, was in einem Seminar passieren soll, kann nicht passieren. Das heißt man braucht kleinere Gruppen, das heißt aber, man braucht mehr Lehrkräfte. In den Schulen gibt es ja auch die Klagen, dass die Klassen zu groß sind und auch das weiß man und da muss man nichts neu erforschen und entdecken, kleinere Gruppen ist der Lehrerfolg größer, kleinere Gruppen bedeutet, mehr Lehrer mehr Geld in die Hand nehmen und geben. Also das sind eine ganze Reihe von Sachen, die relativ einfach zu lösen wären. In der Forschung ist das schwieriger, weil keiner von uns weiß, was sind zukunftsträchtige Forschungsfelder. Da muss man, sage ich mit der Erfahrung von soundsoviel hunderten Jahren Wissenschaftsgeschichte, man muss den Mut haben, offene Felder zu finanzieren. Und das Vertrauen haben, diese Wissenschaftler, denen ich diese Sicherheit gebe, sie forschen in diesen Instituten, irgendwann kommt etwas nützliches raus.
und man weiß noch nicht mal wo.
Man weiß nicht wo und man weiß nicht wann. Aber diesen Vertrauensvorschuss muss man geben.
Aber das ist quasi die Erkenntnis aus den letzten paar hundert Jahren, dass das eben passiert einfach, auch wenn man es nicht vorhersagen kann.
Ja. Weil das ist ja das spannende und schöne, dass diese Überraschungen möglich sind und auch dafür muss ich Freiräume schaffen. Also damit ich jetzt nicht falsch verstanden werde, man muss das nicht sozusagen paradisisch groß treiben, aber man muss einfach diese Freiräume möglich machen in Forschungsorganisationen oder als Präsident an einer Universität, in einer Universität. Und wenn ich mit den alltäglichen Finanzzwängen, wo ich Löcher stopfen muss und neue Löcher aufreiße, dann bleibt einfach kein Raum dafür.
Vielleicht nochmal so zum aktuellen System. Wir sind jetzt ein bisschen schnell hingerauscht, aber die letzte wirklich nennenswerte Umstellung des Wissenschaftssystems, also des eigentlichen Lehrprozesses, war ja dieser Bolognia-Prozess, der quasi überhaupt erst mal so, wie heißt es so schön, die Harmonisierung, also Vereinheitlichung des Lehrsystems europaweit zum Ziel hat und sicherlich auch einiges dadurch einfacher macht, weil eben Bachelor und Master als zwei wohldefinierte Ausbildungsstufen des normalen Universitätsprozesses da natürlich schon ganz andere Vergleichbarkeit schafft, als es bisher war. Es gab ja früher auch oft diese Absurditäten, dass man sein Diplom in irgendwas gemacht hat, aber in einem anderen Land war das halt so, als gäbe es das gar nicht, das kann ja auch nicht sein. Das läuft ja jetzt seit wann? Bolognia-Prozess ist jetzt schon so einige Jahre unterwegs, ich weiß gar nicht, wann ging das los. 88 wurde das mal so erdacht.
Also ernsthaft seit 10 Jahren.
97 ging das glaube ich.
Ernsthaft seit 10 Jahren und seit 97 ist die Umsetzung begonnen worden.
Ja genau, und es dauert ja dann eine Weile, bis die Universitäten darauf umgeschaltet haben.
Ja.
Kann man sagen, dass das positive Auswirkungen hatte? Hat es negative Auswirkungen?
Also ich denke, es ist zu früh. Auf der einen Seite ist das ja eine schöne Idee gewesen und ist sie immer noch. Dass Studentinnen und Studenten heute sagen, also ich bin ein Semester in Berlin und ein Semester in Paris und ein Semester in Madrid und ein Semester in Cambridge UK. Und das geht alles und schließt aneinander an und baut auf. Also das ist die Idealvorstellung und die funktioniert so natürlich nicht. Es hat auch damit zu tun, dass natürlich weniger an Wissenschaftler hier gedacht wird, sondern an die normalen Berufe, die eine akademische Ausbildung brauchen. Und wo die Hoffnung ist, dass das auf dem Arbeitsmarkt dann kompatibler ist und vergleichbarer. Und dass also ein deutscher Absolvent aus München in Spanien eine Stelle findet, weil das ähnlich ist, wie ein spanischer Bewerber. Das steckt alles dahinter und die Umsetzung ist natürlich abhängig, wie in den jeweiligen Ländern der Konsens ist und das Geld vorhanden ist. Und der Bolognia-Prozess in der Umsetzung wird natürlich seit 2007 - also Leeman-Brothers und der ganze Pleitekram - kontakariert mit diesen ganzen Spargeschichten. Weil um Reformen positiv einzuführen, braucht man eigentlich mehr Geld. Und wenn man die Reform machen will und hat gleichzeitig weniger Geld, schafft das neue Probleme, an die vorher keiner gedacht hat. Und wenn also jetzt die Kürzungen überall sind und die Unis Programme wieder abschaffen müssen, die sie versucht haben gerade im Bolognia-Prozess neu zu installieren, um vergleichbar zu sein, dann laufen hier Prozesse gegenläufig und das kann man nur verhindern, indem man also sagt, Wissenschaft und Bildung sind wichtig für das reiche Europa und für alle Länder, die zur Zeit wirtschaftlich größere Probleme haben. Und man muss in der EU einen ähnlichen Konsens versuchen zu finden, wie in der Bundesrepublik. Mit den förderalen Strukturen, so dass man da auch was auffangen kann. Also der Förderalismus ist ja ein gutes Modell, wenn er zu engstirnig gehandhabt wird gibt es auch wieder Probleme. Also wenn es unmöglich wird, dass Kinder in der Schule von Berlin nach München wechseln, weil die Lehrpläne so unterschiedlich sind, dann ist es natürlich falsch. Aber erst mal das so zusagen zu diversifizieren und dabei aber trotzdem eine gewisse Vergleichbarkeit zu halten und dann auch sich wechselseitig zu unterstützen in Zeiten der Not, das ist meiner Meinung nach etwas, was in der europäischen Union erst noch erreicht werden muss. Weil bisher sind ja die Diskurse dann eher so etwas arrogant, die sollen sich mal selber kümmern und wieso wir und wir haben ja die Debatten aber auch in Deutschland. .Also wenn dann die Bayern schimpfen, dass sie immer nur der Nettoeinzahler sind. Wobei wenn sie es auf Dauer wären, hätten sie recht, dass sie sich beklagen, aber man muss eben gucken, wie man das so versucht zu vernetzen, dass die positiven Seiten der förderalen Strukturen, nämlich dass ich überall kleine Zentren habe und gleichzeitig aber die Vergleichbarkeit und die Austauschbarkeit herstelle und mich nicht abschotte. Denn also zum Beispiel im 19. Jahrhundert bei der Lehrerbildung, dass Studenten die Unis wechseln ist also Gang und Gäbe gewesen im 19. Jahrhundert und dass man also ein paar Semester in Hamburg, Göttingen, Berlin, München studiert hat, aber für die jeweiligen Abschlüsse als Lehrer musste man an seine deutsche HEimatuniversität. Also die Preußen hier und die Bayern dort und also das ist dann sozusagen diese Kleinstaaterei gewesen.
Was jetzt nicht mehr so ist.
Nein. Aber ich bringe das nur als Beispiel, um zu sehen, diese förderalen Strukturen haben ganz wichtige positive Elemente und wenn man sie aber zu sehr fokussiert, dann behindern sie wieder. Und wenn ich eben sage, ein Preuße darf nicht in Bayern Lehrer werden oder umgekehrt, dann ist es behindernd.
Aber jetzt abgesehen von der Finanzdebatte, die ich jetzt mal nebenanstellen will, grundsätzlich sagen Sie, ist diese Vereinheitlichung des Lehrsystems etwas, was an sich förderlich sein kann, für die Weiterentwicklung des Wissenschaftssystems als solchem?
Ja und nein. Es darf nicht dazu führen, dass unter der Vereinheitlichung dann gravierende Felder draußen bleiben. Also man muss die Balance hinkriegen. Dass man meinetwegen variable Angebote macht. Also es gibt, würde ich sagen, eine Basis, die überall möglichst ähnlich sein sollte an Wissen und darum herum muss es aber Module geben, die zusätzlich was anbieten und die sollen ruhig unterschiedlich sein und die sollen ruhig ein Grund sein, dass eine Studentin von Göttingen nach Berlin kommt oder nach Paris oder nach Madrid. Und die Balance dessen müssen die jeweiligen Fachwissenschaftler finden. Und die müssen sagen, das und das und das ist zusätzlich das. Und da kann sich auch jede Uni profilieren, weil sie sagt, wir bieten etwas an, was sonst eben erst wieder 2500 Kilometer weiter angeboten wird. Und das wäre sozusagen eine Möglichkeit. Und da können zum Beispiel Mäzene fördern, indem sie die sogenannte Anschubfinanzierung übernehmen oder indem sie Stipendien übernehmen. Weil das ist ja oft hilfreich, dass dann also die ersten fünf Jahre erst mal finanziert werden und dann wird die Bürokratie überzeugt, ja das funktioniert und ist dann bereit es dauerhaft zu bezahlen. Und da denke ich sind Mäzene ganz ganz wichtig, dass sie also Möglichkeiten eröffnen, etwas auszuprobieren.
Und auch mehr Mut auf den Tisch bringen quasi.
Ja. Weil alles andere, wenn man das durch die bürokratischen Prozedere gehen muss, dann bleibt die innovative Idee womöglich auf der Strecke, weil man nur was sicheres anbieten darf und soll. Und da würde ich sagen, da kann man nicht genug werben um Mäzene und auch für solche Stipendienprogramme.
Wenn man jetzt mal von dem eigentlichen Ausbildungsweg hin zum ausgebildeten Wissenschaftler schaut, der dann eben auch versucht, seine Forschung akut zu betreiben, an der Stelle stellt sich ja im Prinzip die selbe Frage. Also wo mache ich das, wo hänge ich meine Forschung auf. Gemeinhin sind es halt einerseits die Universitäten oder wie die Max-Planck-Gesellschaft, eben diese wissenschaftlichen Gesellschaften, die sich zusammentun, um dann wiederum Forschungsinstitute aufzustellen. Gibt es da, also inwiefern muss man das System verstehen, was trägt im Wesentlichen diese Forschungsarbeit jenseits der Universitäten derzeit. Welche Rolle spielen auch Stiftungen in dem Zusammenhang, würde mich nochmal interessieren. Und gibt es dort auch neue Trends, wie sich das noch weiter aufteilen kann.
Also an den Universitäten sind die Möglichkeiten, längerfristig zu forschen, relativ eingeschränkt, dadurch, dass wir kaum unbefristete Stellen haben. Also wirklich nur die Professuren und weil die Lehrverpflichtungen zum Teil sehr hoch sind. Und wo zur Zeit ja viele Diskussionen im Raum sind, ob man so eine zusätzliche Professur einrichtet, die stärker mit der Lehre belastet ist und dann sagen mit Recht viele, das zerstört aber eigentlich diese Einheit von Forschung und Lehre. Also insofern, die Universitäten sind eher dazu da, dass man das Handwerkszeug lernt als Wissenschaftlerin, als Wissenschaftler im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Wenn es um Experimentalwissenschaften geht oder eben das theoretische Rüstzeug. Deutschland ist eigentlich ganz gut aufgestellt. Die Bundesrepublik Deutschland hat nämlich mehrere Forschungsorganisationen. Also die Max-Planck-Gesellschaft ist ja nicht die einzige. Wir haben dann noch die Helmholtz-Gemeinschaft, wir haben die Fraunhofer-Gesellschaft und wir haben als jüngste die Leibniz-Gemeinschaft, die ja so ein Mix ist, also Bürger der alten Bundesrepublik kennen vielleicht noch den Begriff "Blaue Liste", Blaue-Liste-Institute.
Was ist das?
Das waren Institute, Forschungsinstitute, die so irgendwie angedockt waren an Universitäten, aber aus dem staatlichen Haushalt finanziert wurden, warum die Blaue Liste hießen weiß ich nicht. Und dann gab es ja nach der Vereinigung und nach der abgeklungen von DDR-Wissenschaftsinstituten, die die positiv evaluiert wurden und da rumhingen sozusagen, wenn man sich das als Moleküle vorstellt, freischwebend. Und die wurden alle dann in diese Leibniz-Gemeinschaft aufgenommen. Und das ist ein breites Spektrum, wo wissenschaftliche Forschung gemacht werden kann und wo die Bedingungen aber natürlich ganz unterschiedlich sind. Und wer sich interessiert, die haben ja alle in alle inzwischen eine Homepage und Selbstdarstellungen und da kann man das alles nachgucken und verfolgen. Diese wissenschaftlichen Einrichtungen, Forschungseinrichtungen sind schon was sehr positives. Weil sie die Möglichkeit eröffnen, Forschung für einen längeren Zeitraum zu machen unter relativ guten Bedingungen, mit internationaler Vernetzung, mit Kooperationen und das sind schon sehr gute Möglichkeiten für Wissenschaftler. Und der Prozess der Internationalisierung ist ziemlich groß inzwischen bei unserer Max-Planck-Gesellschaft, der ist glaube ich weniger bei den anderen, aber das wird sich zwangsläufig entwickeln und dann gibt es für Naturwissenschaftler spannende Möglichkeiten, in dem was man in der Industrieforschung macht. Das ist eine Stärke gewesen seit dem 19. Jahrhundert, dass die Industrie festgestellt hat, sie braucht ihre eigenen Laboratorien und sie braucht ihre eigenen Wissenschaftler, die bei ihnen an innovativen Produkten sitzen und auch das lehrt die Geschichte wieder, solche Konzerne wie Telefunken oder AEG oder auch Siemens waren international dann sehr erfolgreich, wenn sie ihre Industrieforschung nicht zu klein gehalten haben und nicht zu anwendungsorientiert. Sondern wenn sie denen auch Freiräume gelassen haben. Und damals haben die aber, ich meine, die waren selber zum Teil studierte Naturwissenschaftler und dann hatten die die Ahnung, ich lass die machen, da kommt was raus.
Aber das funktioniert nicht, wenn man es zu eng macht.
Ja, weil dann habe ich natürlich jetzt und morgen ein Produkt, aber nicht in zehn Jahren. Und ich muss die Freiräume lassen und das haben die damals sehr sehr gut verstanden bei Krupp und Co.
Warum funktioniert das nicht? Funktioniert das deshalb nicht, weil die Motivation der Wissenschaftler in zu engen Grenzen erlahmt oder weil man einfach nicht zu breit genug guckt, um überhaupt auf irgendwelche Ergebnisse zu kommen.
Nein, das ist diese Mischung. Ich muss sozusagen, Kreativität passiert nicht von 8-17 Uhr und mit einem Knüppel daneben und es braucht Freiräume und auch Wissenschaftler brauchen diese Freiräume und wie gesagt, wenn man mal zurückguckt, bei AEG und Telefunken, die waren nicht nur fixiert, dass sie die nächste Glühbirne besser herstellen oder entwickeln, sondern die konnten auch spinnen in dem Sinne, also spinnen in Anführungsstrichen und das ist auch etwas, was schwer zu vermitteln ist, aber was wichtig ist.
Weil es manchmal einfach auch nur der glückliche Zufall ist, der einen wirklich auf die...
Ja und dafür, um den Zufall dann auszunutzen muss man diese Möglichkeit haben und muss das sehen und weil so was ist ja auch was spielerisches. Und wenn man guckt, man muss also auch die Zeit lassen zum Spielen, zum Ausprobieren.
Ich sehe gerade so Newton unter dem Baum liegen, wie er dem fallenden Apfel zuschaut.
Wo wir ja nicht wissen, ob es so war. Aber nein, man muss wirklich diese Möglichkeiten schaffen, dass da Gedankenexperimente gemacht werden und neun von zehn erweisen sich als nicht tragfähig, aber der zehnte ist es und dann muss man halt auch die Zeit und die Möglichkeiten lassen, dass das so geht.
Welche Rolle spielen die Stiftungen im wissenschaftlichen Prozess?
Na die Stiftungen spielen natürlich eine immer wichtigere Rolle, weil das Geld immer fehlt. Aber ich würde es positiver formulieren wollen, Stiftungen können sehr schön eine ergänzende und korrigierende Funktion haben, weil alles was ich staatlicherseits einrichte ist ja, wenn ich es überhaupt einrichte, ist ja dann erst nach einer sehr längeren Zeit, wo es scheinbar sicher ist, dass das jetzt wirklich so gemacht werden kann und dann für eine längerfristige. Und Stiftungen bieten den Freiraum etwas auszuprobieren. Weil sie eben wirklich geben können und sagen, in diesen fünf Jahren probiert ihr ein neues Format in der Lehre zum Beispiel und dann schauen wir, ob das funktioniert. Oder in diesen fünf Jahren probiert ihr eine neue Entwicklung in irgendwelchen Bereichen. Also ich denke Stiftungen sind ganz wichtig, um als Korrektiv und Ergänzung zu wirken. Ich meine bisher zumindest ist es Konsens in der Bundesrepublik, dass die Universitäten staatlich getragen werden, es gibt inzwischen die Versuche mit den privaten Universitäten - also ich habe im Rundfunk vor ein paar Wochen eine Art zusammenfassenden Bericht gehört, da waren die alle der Meinung, es ist noch zu früh, um zu entscheiden, ist das nun eine Alternative oder nicht, deshalb will ich mich dazu auch nicht äußern, wenn die das schon selber als Betreiber nicht einschätzen können. Also solange der Konsens ist, Universitäten werden staatlich finanziert, ist der Raum für Stiftungen, da ergänzende Modelle zu finanzieren.
Weil die Stiftungen vor allem auch so bestimmte Themenbereiche durch diese explizite Förderung überhaupt in den Fokus bringen, die sonst so nicht da wären.
Ja, und sie können auch wirklich Neues ausprobieren. Also etwas interdisziplinäres, was wegen der Bürokratie dann schon schwerer an den staatlichen gemacht werden kann. Da denke ich gibt es ganz ganz viele Möglichkeiten. Also gerade jetzt die Neuroforschung kriegt ja nun viel Geld, die brauchen eigentlich nichts zusätzlich, aber das ist so ein Gebiet, da müssen ja Philosophen, Mediziner, Genetiker zusammenarbeiten. Das ist ja mitunter schwer zu organisieren und da wäre für eine Stiftung das ganze einfach. Weil die nicht diese Fakultätsgrenzen überwinden müssen, weil sie gar keine haben.
Die definieren einfach das Aufgabenziel schon von vornherein interdisziplinär.
So ist es. Also ich glaube, gerade für solche neuen Sachen, wo also sicher wollen Stifter und Stiftungsgeber natürlich auch etwas längerfristiges machen, also die wollen nicht nur sagen, hier mal fünf Jahre und dort mal fünf Jahre und da bietet sich aber an, dass Stipendienprogramme finanziert werden und zwar wirklich langfristig, so dass noch stärker in Europa gewandert werden kann. Also für Wissenschaftler. So dass eben wirklich mal jemand ein bis zwei Jahre am Sanaes??? sein kann und dann ein, zwei Jahre am Max-Planck-Institut für irgendwas und dann ein, zwei Jahre in Madrid oder Barcelona oder oder. So dass diese europäische Komponente gefördert wird, das könnte ich mir auch vorstellen, dass es da eine Stiftung gibt, also so wie wir für Studenten dieses Erasmus-Programm haben, was ja sehr gut funktioniert und meine Erfahrungen mit Erasmus-Studenten sind durch die Bank positiv.
Also die Finanzierung einzelner Semester in anderen Ländern.
Und so würde ich mir wünschen, dass man also für ausgebildete Wissenschaftler, ja man kann es ja vielleicht Spinosa-Programm nennen oder oder oder Leibniz, der fuhr ja immer viel rum. Wobei der hatte sich das ja organisiert über seinen Landesherren und hatte dann immer so einen offiziellen Auftrag und dann hat er aber inoffiziell seine wissenschaftlichen Kontakte gepflegt. Also so ein Spinosa- oder Leibniz-Programm zum Wandern und Austausch von Wissenschaftlern.
Teilweise gibt es das ja schon. Also mit Forschungssemestern hat man ja schon die Möglichkeit auch, Förderung zu bekommen, zumindest bestimmte Rahmengelder. Aber Sie sprechen jetzt von einer etwas konsequenteren Umsetzung von so etwas.
Ja eine konsequentere und eine breiter gefächerte. Also wo es also über die Fächer hinaus geht. Das fände ich ein schönes Modell, was man auch wirklich langfristig machen kann.
Was es ja gibt, der interdisziplinäre Teil der interessiert mich auch gleich nochmal, aber damit wir das nicht verlieren, es gibt ja auf EU-Ebene auch entsprechende Förderungen. EU-Projekte, die nicht nur auch Geld bereitstellen für bestimmte Forschungsinhalte und von daher in gewisser Hinsicht, da sie ja auch so agendagetrieben sind, auch so einen ähnliche Rolle einnehmen, denke ich, wie die Stiftungen, kann man das so sagen. Die ja dann auch immer gleich diese Voraussetzung mitbringt, da müssen sich mindestens so und so viele Teams aus verschiedenen Ländern draus beteiligen. Die sich ja in der Regel auch immer ganz fleißig besuchen. Also so in gewisser Hinsicht, so was ähnliches scheint es ja schon zu geben.
Ja es gibt viele verschiedene Formate inzwischen, also bei den EU-Projekten ist es aber eben ein sehr hoher Antragsaufwand. Also ich habe gute Erfahrungen mit Konferenzen, da ist es aber auch einfacher, da findet man drei, vier europäische Länder und die Kollegen aus den Ländern machen zusammen eine Konferenz. Da geht das. Bei Projekten ist es natürlich schwieriger, weil diese sind auf Zeit finanziert und wenn man Chancen haben will, dass man ein Erfolgserlebnis hat, muss man natürlich mit so einem halbfertigen Ding da schon reingehen. Weil sonst weiß man ja nicht, ob man in dem engen Zietraum das schafft. Also insofern das sind alles Möglichkeiten, die aber noch, also die entbürokratisierter werden müssten und noch besser funktionieren könnten. Und wo die einzelnen Länder auch glaube ich mehr ihre Erfahrungen positiv einbringen müssten.
Nochmal zurück zu dieser interdisziplinären Forschung. Also ist das etwas, was gegebenenfalls nicht ausreichend betont wird, dass die einzelnen Wissenschaftsfelder zu wenig gemeinsam arbeiten, oder ist das jetzt eine Unterstellung?
Nein, das kann man so nicht sagen. Es ist aber schwierig. Die Ausbildung erfolgt in einem Ursprungsfach und dann muss man natürlich günstige Möglichkeiten finden als Wissenschaftler, dass man da noch ein zweites oder drittes Spezialgebiet sich aneignen kann, ehe man interdisziplinär fruchtbringend arbeiten kann. Also bleiben wir bei meinem Fach Wissenschaftsgeschichte, das hat ja schon mal mindestens zur Voraussetzung, dass man ein bisschen was über Wissneschaft weiß und dass man also entweder Philosophie oder Geschichte oder Wissenschaftstheorie studiert hat plus man muss mehrere Sprachen möglichst können, damit man dann vergleichend was untersuchen kann. Das heißt eh da ein Ergebnis ist, braucht es erst mal einen gewisse kumulative Phase, um sich das alles anzueignen und das gilt für interdisziplinäre Projekte eigentlich immer, dass erst mal eine Aneignungsphase ist, um wechselseitig sich zu verstehen. Und nun kann man pauschal verallgemeinernd sagen, interdisziplinäre Projekte sind immer spannender, weil da kommen verschiedene Sichtweisen zusammen und da passieren spannende Dinge. Aber sie sind schwerer zu organisieren, in dem Bürokratieverfahren dann wieder abzurechnen. Oder wenn junge Leute das machen sollen und die sollen ihre Dissertationen machen, dann ist es wieder schwieriger mit diesen bürokratischen Verfahren. Also man muss da eine richtige Mischung finden, dass man die Möglichkeiten eröffnet und so offen wie möglich bleibt, aber gleichzeitig muss man es natürlich ein bisschen strukturieren, damit überhaupt eine Chance ist, dass es Ergebnisse gibt. Sonst palavert sich das dann hin. Weil das ist auch das ganz schwierige, solche Forschungsprojekte zu leiten. Da wird oft unterschätzt, da muss man Mitarbeiter alles sein. Da muss man selber ein guter Wissenschaftler sein, man sollte aber auch ein bisschen psychologisch wissen, wer kann mit wem, um bei der Bürokratie nicht einen Nervenzusammenbruch zu kriegen, muss man also ein gewisses bürokratisches Grundwissen sich aneignen. Ja, also das ist, man braucht da mehrere Fähigkeiten.
Vielleicht zum Schluss, auch wenn sich das so schwer verallgemeinern lässt, aber welchen Rat kann man denn so angehenden Wissenschaftlern so mitgeben, wohin man sich vielleicht orientieren sollte. Und zwar jetzt nicht inhaltlich, sondern eben organisatorisch. Wie sollte man sich selbst verstehen als Wissenschaftler. Ich glaube es geht so ein bisschen weg von dem, naja ich such mir hier mein Institut und dann schließe ich mich da irgendwie 30 Jahre ein und dann ist auch irgendwann vorbei.
Nein der Vorteil, den wir haben, wenn wir Wissenschaftler sind, wir können ja lebenslang arbeiten. Also es wird schwierig, wenn man Experimentalwissenschaftler ist und man braucht jetzt diese vielen großen teuren Geräte, weil wie vorhin schon gesagt, in die Küche kann man nicht gehen, und das dort machen, die Experimente. Aber wer theoretisch arbeitet, der kann das ja immer machen, solange wie er und sie sich fit fühlen. Also das ist einer der Vorteile, dass man wenn man Glück hat macht man ja meistens was einem Spaß macht. Und da ist man zwar juristisch an irgendwelche Altersgrenzen gebunden. Also in der Bundesrepublik gibt es ja diese Hürde, der über 50 ist wird auf keine W3-Professur mehr kommen, weil das meistens ausgeschlossen wird. Das ist natürlich in der heutigen Zeit ein bisschen anachronistisch solche Formulierungen, Ausschreibungen, aber von solchen bürokratischen Sachen abgesehen, kann man das immer machen, solange man Spaß hat, Ideen hat, neugierig ist, Neugier ist was ganz wichtiges. Wenn junge Leute in die Wissenschaft gehen wollen, sollten sie weniger gucken, wie die Bezahlung ist. Die ist oft zumindest in den ersten Jahren auch einfach schlicht schlecht, aber sie sollten gucken, ob es ihnen Spaß macht, ob sie Spaß haben, viel Wissen erst mal akumulieren zu müssen, womöglich andere Sprachen lernen zu müssen. Also Englisch ist inzwischen die gemeinsame Wissenschaftssprache, das sollte man sehr früh sich bemühen möglichst gut zu lernen. Und dann sollte man auf seine innere Stimme hören, was man spannend findet und ob es einem Spaß macht. Es gibt natürlich auch noch solche Sachen, die man berücksichtigen muss, also es gibt schon ein gewisses Talent für manche Fächer.
Na gut, aber jetzt sind wir ja bisschen mehr bei dem Werbeflyer überhaupt Wissenschaftler zu werden und sich dann vielleicht die richtige Disziplin auszusuchen. Ich meinte eher, wenn man das schon für sich beschlossen hat, wenn das klar, wenn auch vielleicht die Disziplin feststeht und was dann auch unabhängig jetzt von der Disziplin einfach die Empfehlung ist, wohin sollte man sich orientieren. Was sind die Felder in dem Wissenschaftssystem, die vielversprechend sind, die ein bisschen auch - von Trends will ich jetzt mal nicht reden - aber wo es einfach sinnvoll ist, sich hinzuentwickeln, um einfach auch ein erfolgreiches, spannendes und in jeder Hinsicht unterhaltsames Wissenschaftlerleben dann auch zu führen. Ich meine, es gibt viele neue Möglichkeiten durch die internationale Vernetzung. Das wird ja sicherlich in späteren Folgen auch nochmal ein Thema sein. Was zeichnet sich ab, was den Wissenschaftlerberuf anders werden lässt, als er es vielleicht in den letzten hundert Jahren gewesen ist.
Ich glaube der Wissenschaftlerberuf verändert sich, weil er schneller reagieren muss auf neue Entwicklungen. Es ist einfach wahr, also denken wir an die Computerentwicklung und da ist in den letzten 20 Jahren rapide was passiert. Aber ich glaube schon, dass in dem ganzen Bereich Kybernetik, IT spannende Fragen sind. In unserem eigenen Gebiet habe ich ja gesagt, Wissenschaftsgeschichte, gerade im nichteuropäischen Raum, China, arabischer Raum sind ganz ganz viele offene Forschungsfelder und wird es, wenn die Entwicklung nicht völlig negativ läuft, wird es neue schöne Möglichkeiten geben, da auch vor Ort mit Kollegen Wissenschaftsgeschichte betreiben zu können. Ich glaube es gibt viele spannende Felder in dem Bereich, der zur Medizin hin tendiert, also Pharmakologie, Medizin, es wird bestimmt Neuentwicklung geben bei der Entwicklung neuer Medikamente. Und zwar nicht von der Pharmaindustrie dominiert, sondern aus der Wissenschaft kommend.
Aber jetzt sind wir schon wieder so beim inhaltlich. Ich wollte, meine Frage ging jetzt ins organisatorische. Wie stellt man sich auf, wie vernetzt man sich, was sind die besten.
Das hat aber viel mit dem Inhalt zu tun. Also wenn ich an Mathematikerinnen und Mathematiker denke, die sind nicht so abhängig von Ressourcen, von Forschungsgeräten, von Forschungstechnik. Da ist es also viel einfacher, sich vorzustellen, ich gehe in den Ort X oder Y und mache dort meine Zahlentheorie. Und andere, die an solche Forschungsinstrumente gebunden sind, für die stellt sich die Frage anders. Die müssen dann gucken, wo ist da die Möglichkeit, dass ich auch wirklich mit den modernsten Geräten was machen kann. Weil das ist dann für manche Gebiete einfach wichtig. Und da ist innerhalb der europäischen Union sind die Chancen relativ gut. Also außerhalb der europäischen Union haben es junge Wissenschaftler viel viel schwerer, an simple Ressourcen zu kommen. Ihre Ergebnisse zu publizieren. Und insofern es ist immer geknüpft ein bisschen an den Inhalt. Weil je nachdem, welche inhaltichen Dinge ich mache, haeb ich bestimmte Rahmenbedingungen.
Aber so dieses Vernetzen von unterschiedlichen Disziplinen ist ja im Prinzip viel einfacher geworden. Wir haben ja vorhin schon gesagt, interdisziplinäre Forschung ist an sich für ein Forschungsgegenstand von Vorteil, wäre es da nicht auch angeraten, dass man sich vielleicht grundsätzlich so orientiert, dass man auch selbst wenn man sein eigenes Feld, man sehr viel bewusster in Bereiche reinschaut, die vielleicht auf den ersten Blick auch gar nichts damit zu tun haben.
Ja natürlich, das meinte ich vorhin mit Neugier. Also man muss offen sein, neugierig sein, sozusagen um beim Bild zu bleiben, man ist in einem Gebäude mit vielen verschlossenen Türen und man muss Lust haben, die alle aufzumachen. Selbst wenn da steht, im Märchen gibt es doch dann, in den Raum darfst du nicht gehen. Und dann muss man trotzdem da gucken.
Das verborgene Zimmer. Die Tür muss geöffnet werden.
Und das ist, Neugier ist ganz wichtig, und Türen öffnen. Also keine Hemmungen haben. Und es ist ja inzwischen relativ leicht, durch diese Internetgeschichten und man kann da also sehr schnell finden, wo in den einzelnen Ländern es eventuell Partner gibt, mit denen ich Kontakt haben will. Institutionen, Institute, Leute. Und auch das sollte man einfach nutzen. Also so, wie man auf jemanden zugeht und sagt, ich möchte mit Ihnen reden, so kann man das im Internet schon mal anfangen. Und dann stellt sich heraus, ja man trifft sich, man redet.
Ja, Annette Vogt, jetzt sind wir am Ende angekommen. Vielen Dank.
Miteinander reden, was wir gemacht haben die ganze Zeit.
Genau das ist sehr wichtig. Das werden wir dann hier in der Serie von Forschergeist auch noch weiterhin fleißig tun. Zu einer großen Bandbreite von Themen. Ich werde jetzt mal noch nichts verraten. Aber ich weiß ja schon ein wenig wohin die Reise geht und es ist auf jeden Fall ein buntes Bouquet geplant, insofern vielen Dank nochmal Frau Vogt. Und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören hier bei der ersten Folge von Forschergeist, es geht bald weiter, bis dahin noch Tschüss bis bald.